Lucia: 啊哎这也是牛奶
Lucia: Ah, hey, this is also milk.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 那个好的
Lucia: That one then.
Jake:我靠这已经是汤了
Jake: Damn, this is already soup.
Lucia: 我放一下
Lucia: I'll put this down.
Lucia: sorry谢谢
Lucia: Sorry, thanks.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:这冰淇淋这麦旋风
Jake: This ice cream, this McFlurry.
Jake:饮这汤呢有用吗
Jake: Drinking this soup, is it any good?
其他人:有有有
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:那就动一下放到下面就行
Jake: Just move it down a bit and it'll be fine.
Alice:你放下边
Alice: Put it down there.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Katrina: 有只苍蝇
Katrina: There's a fly.
Lucia: 这应该是热巧克力吧
Lucia: This should be hot chocolate, right?
Jake:哈呃自取灭亡
Jake: Haha, self-destruction.
Shure: 哈哈没事
Shure: Haha, it's fine.
Shure: 高蛋白
Shure: High protein.
Jake:给给您吃哈哈
Jake: Here, you eat it, haha.
Shure: 这是油还是啊
Shure: Is this oil or what?
Shure: 哇谁这么奢侈
Shure: Wow, who's so extravagant?
Shure: 点的安格斯候牛榜
Shure: Ordered an Angus thick beef burger.
Lucia: 哎呦喂sorry
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
Lucia: 扔个垃圾先说
Lucia: Gonna throw out some trash first.
Tasha:之前说吃安格斯厚牛堡的都是渣女
Tasha: Didn't they say people who eat Angus thick beef burgers are all jerks?
Tasha:你是捞女是吧是吗
Tasha: Are you a gold digger or what?
Lucia: 不好意思是吗
Lucia: Sorry, what?
Tasha: 是有那个梗是吧
Tasha: It's a joke, right?
Tasha:你个low女
Tasha: You low-class girl.
Shure: 不能吃便宜的
Shure: Can't eat cheap stuff.
Lucia: 好像是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Shure: 烤这么贵的
Shure: Gotta grill the expensive ones.
Lucia: 我点的好像是这个和薯条和热巧克力
Lucia: I think I ordered this with fries and hot chocolate.
Jake:盲盒盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind box, blind box, blind box.
Jake:还有谁没挑吗
Jake: Anyone hasn't picked yet?
Lucia: 乱拆
Lucia: Open it randomly.
Jake:谁有派吗
Jake: Who has a pie?
Jake:派是怎么点的
Jake: How did you order the pie?
Tasha:派是我点
Tasha: I ordered the pie.
Tasha:我点了两个派
Tasha: I ordered two pies.
Lucia: 是这个吗
Lucia: Is this it?
Tasha:给你一个
Tasha: Here, have one.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 管他呢就当是这个了
Lucia: Whatever, let's just say this is it.
Jake:薯条薯条都是谁
Jake: Who got the fries?
Jake:薯条就分着吃吧
Jake: Let's just share the fries.
Jake:但是没有地方放呢要不然
Jake: But there's no place to put them, otherwise...
Jake:怎么找不到呵呵呵呃OK OK
Jake: How come I can't find it, hehe, okay, okay.
Lucia: 把这一挪
Lucia: Move this over.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:哎呀呀呀好损失了8根
Jake: Oh no, we lost 8 of them.
Lucia: 对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:麦当劳薯条
Jake: McDonald's fries.
Katrina: 嗯好冷啊
Katrina: Hmm, it's so cold.
Jake:薯条这叫什么呀这叫
Jake: What do you call these fries?
Jake:薯条自由是吗
Jake: Fries freedom, right?
Lucia: 番茄酱在哪个袋子里呢
Lucia: Which bag is the ketchup in?
Lucia: 才给这么点番茄酱
Lucia: They only gave this little ketchup.
Tasha:今天晚上怎么吃这么好
Tasha: Why are we eating so well tonight?
Tasha:我们是要走路了吗
Tasha: Are we going for a walk?
Katrina: 牛排
Katrina: Steak.
Tasha:要上路了是吧
Tasha: Are we hitting the road?
Tasha:我说今天晚上怎么吃这么好吃
Tasha: I was wondering why we are eating so well tonight.
Tasha:要上路了
Tasha: We're hitting the road.
Katrina: 还有的宝呢
Katrina: Where's the treasure?
Jake:呃还还有很多
Jake: Uh, there's still a lot.
Jake:也没有很多了
Jake: Not really a lot.
Jake:还有几个
Jake: There are a few left.
Lucia: 为啥你是直接挤在上面的
Lucia: Why did you squeeze it directly on top?
Lucia: 我以为是挤在旁边然后站的那种
Lucia: I thought you were supposed to squeeze it on the side.
Jake:哦OK那也行
Jake: Oh, OK, that works too.
Lucia: 没事都行
Lucia: It's fine, whatever.
Lucia: 无所谓了好
Lucia: Doesn't matter, it's fine.
Jake:好好挤旁边合理
Jake: OK, squeezing on the side makes sense.
其他人:这个能吃了吗
Others: Can we eat this now?
Jake:这个不可以吃
Jake: This can't be eaten.
Tasha:不给吃我们要摆盘呢
Tasha: No eating, we need to plate it.
Tasha:OK OK杨老师
Tasha: OK, OK, Mr. Yang.
Tasha:嗯你能把桌子收一下
Tasha: Hmm, can you clear the table?
Tasha:把外面的所有台位吗
Tasha: All the tables outside?
Tasha:你能摆一下吗
Tasha: Can you set it up?
Jake:好
Jake: OK.
Katrina: 有一盒薯条
Katrina: There's a box of fries.
Lucia: 居然这么多薯条
Lucia: So many fries!
Alice:薯条开会
Alice: Fries meeting.
Katrina: 哈哈薯条山
Katrina: Haha, fries mountain.
Tasha: 盐我都放到那了
Tasha: I put all the salt there.
其他人:卧槽
Others: Whoa!
Alice:太搞笑了
Alice: That's hilarious.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 我要小开个会了家人们
Shure: I'm going to start a meeting, everyone.
Jake:还有3个宝是谁的
Jake: Whose are the remaining three treasures?
Jake:有一个是我的
Jake: One of them is mine.
Jake:可能吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake:这个可以开
Jake: This one can be opened.
Shure: 要开个会
Shure: We need to have a meeting.
Jake:你关了吧
Jake: You should turn it off.
Jake:你关了吧你开会
Jake: Turn it off and start the meeting.
Jake:你再开嘛
Jake: You can start it again.
其他人：你喜欢哪种薯条
Others: Which kind of fries do you like?
其他人：我都可以
Others: I'm okay with any kind.
其他人：其实我喜欢吃薯条
Others: Actually, I like eating fries.
其他人:我靠我草
Others: Oh my god.
其他人:感动死我了
Others: I'm so touched.
Jake:我嗨了啊
Jake: I'm so hyped.
Jake:我嗨了呃开会
Jake: I'm hyped, let's have a meeting.
其他人:呃开会
Others: Uh, let's have a meeting.
Lucia: 这个拆开放这可以蘸
Lucia: You can open this and dip it.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 虽然我也不知道甜辣酱蘸着好不好吃
Lucia: Though I'm not sure if it tastes good with the sweet chili sauce.
其他人:他刚让我妈拆开一个bug
Others: He just asked my mom to open a bug.
其他人:他要他来一个我写bug
Others: He wants to do it, I'm writing the bug.
Lucia: 嗯还行
Lucia: Hmm, it's okay.
其他人:哎怎么这么多厚图包
Others: Why are there so many thick packages?
Jake:盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind boxes, blind boxes.
Lucia: 啊不好意思
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
其他人:你想想你当时点的那个
Others: Think about the one you ordered.
其他人:我点的我点的应该是培根
Others: The one I ordered should be bacon.
其他人:啊培根
Others: Ah, bacon.
其他人:那可能我给你吃了
Others: Maybe I ate yours.
Tasha:哇
Tasha: Wow.
其他人:但我记得我点的培根
Others: But I remember ordering bacon.
其他人:怎么还开火了
Others: Why is the stove still on?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:什么牛排
Jake: What steak?
其他人：怎么还开火
Others: Why is the stove still on?
其他人:牛排是不是刘太监的
其他人:哦我想起来我菜的菜
Others: Oh, I remember my dish.
Jake:他怎么发成这样了
Jake: How did he send it like this?
其他人:不好意思
Others: Sorry
Jake:我我我
Jake: I, I, I
Jake:我看看怎么收拾
Jake: Let me see how to clean this up
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry
Jake:这个怎么收掉
Jake: How do I clean this up?
Tasha:还有一块谁来认领一下
Tasha: There's one more piece, who wants it?
Jake:认领一下放牛排里吧
Jake: Claim it and put it with the steak
其他人：卧槽要吗
Others: Whoa, do you want it?
Tasha: 要吗
Tasha: Do you want it?
Tasha: 啊不要不要
Tasha: Ah, never mind
Tasha: 剩这一块啊
Tasha: This one is left
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
其他人：以前我在上海吃学生
Others: Back in Shanghai, I used to eat with students
其他人：那傻屌地方不是只有那个中国总厨吗
Others: That silly place only had a Chinese head chef, right?
其他人：天天去吃麦当劳
Others: We ate McDonald's every day
其他人：那天给我吃吐了
Others: That day I got sick from it
其他人：一点都不想吃
Others: I don't want to eat it anymore
Jake:是这种吗
Jake: Is it like this?
其他人：是
Others: Yes
Jake:一样的
Jake: The same
其他人：汉堡了这个是你的
Others: Here's your burger
Jake:这个丢掉哈
Jake: Throw this away
Jake:丢掉吗丢掉
Jake: Throw it away, okay?
Tasha:丢掉
Tasha: Throw it away
Lucia: 案板
Lucia: Cutting board
Tasha:这你刚吃的芒果菠萝是吗
Tasha: Is this the mango and pineapple you just ate?
Jake:这有差别吗
Jake: Is there a difference?
Alice:哎呦我去
Alice: Oh my gosh
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger
其他人:今天中午吃汉堡晚上吃麦当劳
Others: Had burgers for lunch, McDonald's for dinner
Katrina: 我要坐一下走累了
Katrina: I need to sit down, I'm tired from walking
Alice:还有垃圾吗
Alice: Any more trash?
Jake:有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag
Jake:嗯不好意思扔个垃圾
Jake: Hmm, excuse me, throw the trash away
Jake:这边有垃圾袋
Jake: There's a trash bag here
Alice:这个
Alice: This one
Lucia: 这我的还没吃完
Lucia: I haven't finished mine yet
Lucia: 现在我想着先在这放一下
Lucia: I'll leave it here for now
Lucia: 然后整理一下
Lucia: Then I'll clean up
其他人：有蛋清这是你的吗
Others: There's egg white, is this yours?
Alice:蛋清
Alice: Egg white
Jake:呢
Jake: Hmm?
Katrina: 不是公共的
Katrina: It's not public
Jake:大伙了大伙了
Jake: Everyone, everyone
Alice:蛋黄打打进那里面了
Alice: The egg yolk got mixed in there
Jake:蘸个酱
Jake: Dip it in some sauce
Jake:哦这还有个
Jake: Oh, there's another one
Jake:我靠开不了啊
Jake: Damn, I can't open it
Lucia: 秀硕的这个乐器
Lucia: Shure's instrument
Alice:你在欣赏自己的作品吗
Alice: Are you admiring your own work?
Alice:无纺一分熟也是熟
Alice: Even if it's just a little done, it's still cooked
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh?
Jake:我把酱开了
Jake: I opened the sauce
Jake:鸡块没了
Jake: No more chicken nuggets
Jake:哈哈是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Jake:还有两只
Jake: There are two more
Jake:在哪啊瞎不好意思
Jake: Where are they? Sorry, I missed them
Lucia: 不是这个也可以蘸
Lucia: You can dip this too
其他人:吃麦当劳为什么不需要蘸酱
Others: Why don't you need sauce for McDonald's?
Jake:为什么呢不知道
Jake: Why is that? I don't know
Katrina: 你是哪人啊
Katrina: Where are you from?
Alice:无妨
Alice: Doesn't matter
其他人：河南人
Others: Henan
Katrina: 我听不出一点口音
Katrina: I can't hear any accent
Katrina: 所以我很好奇
Katrina: So I'm curious
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed
Katrina: 我当时还以为你是北京人哈哈
Katrina: I thought you were from Beijing, haha
其他人:我说话没有精盐味
Others: I don't have a strong accent
其他人:味道不纯
Others: The flavor isn't pure
其他人:但
Others: But
其他人:我确实很好的融入了北京的社会环境
Others: I really integrated well into Beijing's social environment
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Jake:怎么热爱挤地
Jake: Why do you love squeezing into the subway?
Jake:铁哼哼哼
Jake: Iron hum hum hum
其他人:不热爱挤地铁
Others: I don't love squeezing into the subway
其他人:真的
Others: Really
其他人:我在北京上海实习之后我喜欢上海
Others: After interning in Beijing and Shanghai, I prefer Shanghai
其他人:最重要一点就是
Others: The most important thing is
其他人:因为我在上海打车便宜
Others: Because taxis are cheaper in Shanghai
其他人:因为上海最省
Others: Because Shanghai is the most economical
Alice:基本全熟吧
Alice: It's almost fully cooked, right?
Lucia: 哇哦
Lucia: Wow
Alice:哈哈哈哎
Alice: Hahaha hey
其他人：哎你这个时候应该给你哎给他找点盐
Others: Hey, at this point, you should get him some salt.
其他人：对我还没放
Others: Yeah, I haven't added it yet.
其他人：不不你拿就就这样就这样就这样
Others: No, no, just take it, just like this, just like this.
其他人：撒盐哥那个撒法
Others: Like the way Salt Bae does it.
其他人：一定要撒
Others: You have to sprinkle it.
其他人：一定要把那个手腕
Others: You have to use your wrist.
其他人：能怎么激情怎么激情
Others: Make it as passionate as possible.
其他人：然后给你拍一下撒盐哥那个撒法
Others: Then we'll take a shot of you doing the Salt Bae sprinkle.
Alice:那不是哎
Alice: Isn't that hey
Alice:那不是吗
Alice: Isn't that?
Alice:那不是盐吗
Alice: Isn't that salt?
Alice:那个那个
Alice: That one, that one.
Jake:拍摆
Jake: Pose for the shot.
Jake:开摆开摆
Jake: Strike a pose.
Katrina: 洗了吗
Katrina: Did you wash it?
Alice:用那个湿纸巾擦一擦
Alice: Just wipe it with a wet tissue.
Lucia: 厨房纸
Lucia: Kitchen paper.
Alice:哈哈等一下拍你你要摆一下吗
Alice: Hahaha, wait, let me take a picture, do you want to pose?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Lucia: 就可以用这个吗
Lucia: Can I use this?
Lucia: 不能只能用那那个那种纸吗
Lucia: Or can I only use that kind of paper?
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 湿纸巾湿纸巾
Lucia: Wet tissue, wet tissue.
Jake:撒盐啊或者餐巾纸加水也行
Jake: Sprinkle salt or use a napkin with water.
Tasha: 或者餐巾纸加水也行
Tasha: Or use a napkin with water.
Jake:撒一个撒一个
Jake: Sprinkle some, sprinkle some.
Lucia: 要不拿那个
Lucia: How about using that?
Jake:撒了吧你
Jake: Just sprinkle it.
Jake:还没撒呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled it yet.
Lucia: 拿这个加水好了
Lucia: Just use this with water.
其他人:有点小浪费
Others: A bit wasteful.
其他人:撒那个吧
Others: Just sprinkle that.
其他人:这个有点太咸了
Others: This one's a bit too salty.
其他人:撒这个再撒这个
Others: Sprinkle this and then sprinkle that.
Alice:撒过了
Alice: Already sprinkled.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow
Jake:打他是不是从那边外面拍
Jake: Hit him, should we film from over there?
Lucia: 哎呦sorry
Lucia: Oh sorry
Jake:从外面拍从外面拍
Jake: Film it from the outside, film it from the outside
Lucia: 蘸一点蘸一点
Lucia: Dip it a little, dip it a little
其他人:这个这个直接装盘吗
Others: Should we just plate this directly?
Lucia: 哇看起来好好吃
Lucia: Wow, it looks so delicious
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 好好看啊
Lucia: It looks so good
Lucia: 先
Lucia: First
Lucia: 如果我们害怕他太腥了的话也
Lucia: If we’re worried it’s too fishy
Lucia: 是不是可以给底下铺一层那个
Lucia: Can we put a layer of that...
Lucia: 那个那个叫什么
Lucia: What’s it called...
Lucia: 油纸还是烘焙纸那种纸
Lucia: Parchment paper or baking paper, that kind of paper
Lucia: 因为感觉这个刚拆开的话
Lucia: Because when you just unwrap it
Lucia: 不知道他有一些味什么的
Lucia: You don’t know if there’s a smell or something
Lucia: 散散散完了没有
Lucia: Is it gone, is it gone?
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 对要不就铺一个那个对在最底下有
Lucia: Yeah, or we can just put a layer, yeah, at the very bottom
Alice:我拿一下在这里吧我记得
Alice: I'll get it, it should be here, I think
Katrina: 这是在为明天做准备吗
Katrina: Is this for tomorrow’s preparation?
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: I think so
Alice:怎么这么烂
Alice: Why is it so bad?
Lucia: 对他这个是有一点颜色还会
Lucia: Yeah, it has a bit of color and
Lucia: 如果一用水一擦还会掉一些
Lucia: If you wipe it with water, some might come off
Jake:这抬得越高越好
Jake: The higher you lift, the better
Alice:铺吗
Alice: Should I put it down?
Alice:那我搁那了
Alice: I’ll leave it here then
Lucia: 让一下可以吗
Lucia: Can you move a bit?
其他人:真的刘帅
Others: Really, Choiszt
其他人:我要是女生我嫁
Others: If I were a girl, I’d marry him
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵呵可惜
Jake: Hahahahaha, too bad
Lucia: 啊sorry可惜
Lucia: Ah, sorry, too bad
Alice:可以直接捏吗
Alice: Can I just pinch it?
Jake:可惜啊
Jake: Too bad
Lucia: 吃一个哦
Lucia: Eat one
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm
Jake:嗯好吃
Jake: Mm, delicious
Jake:确实可以确实可以
Jake: It’s really good, really good
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow
Jake:确实很可以
Jake: It’s really good
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
其他人:凑巧做做成了一次
Others: It just happened by chance.
其他人:有没有非常的谦虚啊
Others: Aren't you being very humble?
其他人:如果我是一个女生
Others: If I were a girl...
其他人:我就非常喜欢谦虚的男人
Others: I'd really like a humble man.
其他人:哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha
Katrina: 你已经掩盖不了你爱上他的事实
Katrina: You can't hide the fact that you're in love with him.
其他人:我自从有一次点了麦当劳的牛奶
Others: Ever since I ordered McDonald's milk once,
其他人:麦当劳的牛奶非常的牛
Others: McDonald's milk is really good.
Jake:嗯好喝
Jake: Yeah, it's delicious.
Lucia: 这渣怎么掉不出来啊
Lucia: Why won't this residue come out?
Jake:渣木头渣
Jake: It's wood residue.
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 就是拿拿厨房纸擦一下的话
Lucia: If you wipe it with kitchen paper,
Lucia: 厨房纸会掉一些小渣
Lucia: the kitchen paper will leave some residue.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 这里面也铺那个啥算了
Lucia: It's better to line it with parchment paper.
Lucia: 也铺那个油纸算
Lucia: Line it with parchment paper.
其他人:我看啥时候跟女朋友分手
Others: I'll see when I break up with my girlfriend.
Lucia: 放我这
Lucia: Leave it here.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha:好恶毒
Tasha: That's so mean.
Lucia: 再来一个
Lucia: Let's do another one.
其他人:哈哈哈时间管理大师
Others: Hahaha, master of time management.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:给薇薇留一个
Alice: Save one for Vivi.
其他人：你女朋友也没有了
Others: You don't have a girlfriend either.
其他人：嗯女朋友也没有了
Others: Yeah, no girlfriend either.
Alice:给薇薇
Alice: For Vivi.
其他人： 不是她在北京吗在
Others: Isn't she in Beijing?
其他人：在
Others: Yes.
Alice:哎没纸了
Alice: Oh no, we're out of paper.
Jake:今天还要做几道几道甜点
Jake: How many more desserts do we need to make today?
Jake:快完成的3道
Jake: Almost three more to go.
其他人：快点先没电了
Others: Hurry up, we're running out of power.
Tasha: 充电宝没电了快乐
Tasha: The power bank is out of battery, happy now?
其他人：来师傅
Others: Come on, master.
Jake:会优秀员工
Jake: Excellent employee.
Jake:这就是一路在记录
Jake: This is all being recorded.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Jake:开会啊
Jake: Meeting time.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
其他人：你按上沾这个了
Others: You pressed it and got this on.
Lucia: 但是还挺好吃
Lucia: But it's still quite tasty.
Jake:你们明天都呃决定了
Jake: Have you all decided for tomorrow?
Jake:几个人啊
Jake: How many people?
Jake:一个
Jake: One.
Jake:几个
Jake: A few?
Katrina: 一堆
Katrina: A bunch.
Jake:哼哼哼你有一堆啊
Jake: Haha, you have a bunch?
其他人:嗯对
Others: Yeah, right.
其他人:这环球拉人魂未取消啊
Others: This global event hasn't been canceled, huh?
Jake:走现在走
Jake: Let's go now.
Jake:呵呵呵没有没有没有取消了
Jake: Haha, no, no, it hasn't been canceled.
Jake:怕怕外边的人挺麻烦
Jake: Afraid those outside people are quite troublesome.
其他人：让他们来这玩
Others: Let them come and play here.
其他人：人均100 交点伙食费
Others: 100 per person, just pay a bit for food.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:卖门票对
Jake: Sell tickets, right.
Alice:什么门票
Alice: What tickets?
其他人：门票
Others: Tickets.
Jake:看看能不能把这几天本给毁了
Jake: See if we can cover the costs in a few days.
其他人:我跟你讲
Others: I'm telling you.
其他人:你去海淀黄庄门口
Others: Go to Haidian Huangzhuang.
其他人：将来可以给你孩子出
Others: In the future, you can publish for your child.
Jake:海淀黄庄
Jake: Haidian Huangzhuang.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Oh my god, oh my god.
其他人：哎你说他们
Others: Hey, you said they.
其他人：谁说 1,000多个人
Others: Who said over a thousand people.
Jake:不是你组个名字就一天
Jake: No, if you form a name, it's just one day.
Jake:开玩笑呵呵可以
Jake: Just kidding, haha, can do.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Jake:才才数一天吗
Jake: Just count one day?
其他人：在地铁门口
Others: At the subway entrance.
其他人：早上有带着小孩家长
Others: In the morning, parents with kids.
其他人：要不要来参加我们的这个活动
Others: Want to join our event?
其他人:你的孩子
Others: Your child.
其他人:将来有可能会出现在我们的论文里面
Others: Might appear in our papers in the future.
其他人:我们是做AI的
Others: We're working on AI.
其他人:你知道我们女子今年开始的高峰赛道
Others: Do you know our women's peak competition track starts this year?
其他人::你不想想你的孩子不能输在起跑
Others: Don't you think your child can't lose at the starting line?
其他人:孩子升到初中正好结婚
Others: When the child goes to middle school, it's just the right time to get married.
其他人:是开初中赛道了
Others: We're opening the middle school track.
其他人:对
Others: Yes.
Lucia: 哎呦对不起对不起
Lucia: Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
其他人:海淀皇上那味可抽
Others: The Haidian Emperor's flavor is strong.
其他人:我操我知道海淀皇上初中
Others: Damn, I know about Haidian Emperor's middle school.
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Alice:妈呀还薯条泛滥了
Alice: Oh my, there are fries everywhere.
其他人:那你不是在海淀皇上捡生捡死吗
Others: Weren't you struggling to survive in Haidian Emperor?
Lucia: 好多呀
Lucia: There's so many!
其他人:我感觉
Others: I feel...
其他人:我感觉你应该不属于那种极度激娃的
Others: I feel like you don't belong to the extremely intense parenting type.
其他人:真的吗
Others: Really?
其他人:还有我身边的人都是小学
Others: And everyone around me is in elementary school.
Katrina: 这好可爱
Katrina: This is so cute.
其他人:初中什么上课的班的人
Others: Middle school classes, what kind?
Katrina: 比那个比那个网图要好看哎
Katrina: It looks better than the online pictures.
其他人:都是都带海带王装啊
Others: They all wear seaweed king outfits.
其他人:都带海带王装吗
Others: Do they all wear seaweed king outfits?
其他人:对这都是什么人大富人我
Others: Yeah, what kind of rich people are they?
Katrina: 还有一个大的尾巴
Katrina: And there's a big tail.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
其他人:感觉我跟他们人大富人接触一下
Others: I feel like I'm interacting with those rich people.
其他人:他们人大富人确实挺厉害的
Others: Those rich people are really impressive.
其他人:哎你
Others: Hey, you...
其他人:你身边有人大富人吗
Katrina: 不这是我自己的
Katrina: No, this is my own.
其他人:有叫啥
Katrina: 他送我还差不多
Katrina: He gave it to me, almost.
Alice:我可以看一下吗
Alice: Can I take a look?
Katrina: 我送抱着没事
Katrina: I'll hold it, no problem.
Jake:恭喜进入
Katrina: 这我公费埋汰
Katrina: It's my public expense, tarnished.
Alice:这是狐狸吗
Alice: Is this a fox?
Katrina: 对公费吗
Katrina: Yes, public expense?
Katrina: 跟他说这个
Katrina: Tell him this.
其他人：他也太可爱了吧
Others: He's too cute.
其他人： 我一定要嫁给这一生
Others: I must marry him in this life.
其他人:是不
Others: Isn't it?
其他人:是
Others: Yes.
其他人:对
Others: Right.
其他人:非常的非常的夸张
Others: Extremely, extremely exaggerated.
其他人:这
Others: This...
其他人:我之前是参加此期实践的时候认识的
Others: I got to know during the last practice.
其他人:当时我也能打
Others: I could also play at that time.
其他人:所以明天人越多越好
Others: So the more people, the better for tomorrow.
其他人:你
Others: You...
其他人: 女朋友啊
Others: Girlfriend?
Jake:你开两辆车过来
Jake: You drive over with two cars.
其他人:又堵车没有没有没有
Others: Traffic jam again? No, no, no.
Jake:这可以别人也开吗
Jake: Can others also drive?
其他人:我想想我今天去海边王岛
Others: Let me think, I went to the beach island today.
其他人:每次带的地方
Others: The usual place we go.
其他人:下一站都会去新中关购物中
Others: The next stop is always the New Zhongguan Shopping Mall.
其他人:心或者林展购物中心玩耍
Others: Or the Linzhan Shopping Center for fun.
其他人:丝毫没有
Others: Not at all.
其他人:体会到海边王岛的危险的地方
Others: Didn't feel the danger of the beach island at all.
其他人:明天几点
Others: What time tomorrow?
Jake:下午两点半两点半
Jake: 2:30 PM, 2:30 PM.
其他人：下午两点半
Others: 2:30 PM.
其他人:两点半
Alice:还有这个酱
Alice: And this sauce.
Jake:你刚才说有这个伊罗币
Jake: You just said there is this Ero currency.
Jake:过来踩伊罗币
Jake: Come over and step on Ero currency.
其他人:其实说的很好玩
Others: Actually, it sounds fun.
Alice:好多呀
Alice: So many!
Jake:嗯行
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake:白吃白喝
Jake: Free food and drinks.
Jake:就是白吃白喝
Jake: Just free food and drinks.
其他人:免费接送加白吃白喝嗯
Others: Free pick-up and free food and drinks, hmm.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
Alice:明天还负责接送的吗
Alice: Are we still responsible for pick-up tomorrow?
Alice:比较难吧
Alice: It's quite difficult, right?
Jake:嗯对他们北欧的可以方便
Jake: Hmm, yes, it’s more convenient for those from Northern Europe.
Lucia: 他们学校的同学可以
Lucia: Their schoolmates can.
Jake:海淀那边的方便一点
Jake: It's more convenient for those from Haidian.
Alice:这离地铁站远吗 1号线
Alice: Is this far from the subway station? Line 1?
其他人:不远
Others: Not far.
Jake:我们可以到地铁站里面没问题
Jake: We can get to the subway station, no problem.
其他人:对可以给他搞一个
Others: Yeah, we can get him one.
其他人:地铁站到那个接驳车
Others: From the subway station to the shuttle bus.
其他人:大概半个小时一趟
Others: About every half hour.
其他人:还是来过一次哈哈哈
Others: Still, come once, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈其他人：
Lucia: Hahaha, others:
Jake:那就开始啊那不行
Jake: Then let's start, if not.
其他人:哦他可以不按照那个路
Others: Oh, he can follow the route.
其他人:所以我不是借拨车吗
Others: So, isn't it the shuttle bus?
Jake:对呵呵呵呵
Jake: Yes, hahahaha.
其他人：不要背着他过来
Others: Don't bring him over secretly.
Jake:你你再租个车
Jake: You, you rent another car.
Jake:然后给死亡开
Jake: And then drive to death.
Tasha:在这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Lucia: 好像在那上面
Lucia: Seems to be up there.
Lucia: 不是要用刀切一下呀
Lucia: Don't we need to cut it with a knife?
Jake:哎这个蛋挞怎么是个饼啊
Jake: Hey, why is this egg tart a pancake?
Jake:一眼看到了
Jake: I saw it at a glance.
Jake:很好看的一个
Jake: It's a very good-looking one.
Alice:哇熔岩蛋糕
Alice: Wow, lava cake.
Jake:哇
Jake: Wow.
Tasha:哎刮刀呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the scraper?
Tasha:我以为你拿了
Tasha: I thought you took it.
Jake:麦
Jake: Mic.
Lucia: 我来吃
Lucia: I'll eat.
Lucia: 刮刀在哪
Lucia: Where's the scraper?
其他人：挂到吗这个
Others: Scraper? This one?
Lucia: 呃不是
Lucia: Uh, no.
Lucia: 这个是一个塑料的对吧
Lucia: This is a plastic one, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Lucia: 塑料的
Lucia: Plastic one.
Tasha:速速的把它洗一下谢谢
Tasha: Quickly wash it, thanks.
Jake:麦当劳
Jake: McDonald's.
Lucia: 呃要是
Lucia: Uh, if...
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake:我们高级东西可多
Jake: We have a lot of high-end stuff.
Jake:很多我们不理解的东西
Jake: A lot of things we don't understand.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Jake:抹哪啊
Jake: Where to apply it?
Jake:抹抹头上
Jake: Apply it on the head.
Jake:一掌拍下去
Jake: Slap it down with a palm.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha:我每天都这样吃
Tasha: I eat like this every day.
Jake:每天一公斤糖
Jake: One kilogram of sugar every day.
其他人：吃这晚饭
Others: Eat this for dinner.
Jake:这几天伙食太好了这个
Jake: The food has been too good these days.
Alice:剪刀
Alice: Scissors.
Alice:剪刀在哪里
Alice: Where are the scissors?
其他人:这奶油是吧
Others: This is cream, right?
Jake:对就是奶油
Jake: Yes, it's cream.
Jake:剪下来了吗
Jake: Did you cut it off?
其他人:嗯不甜
Others: Hmm, not sweet.
Tasha:没有
Tasha: No.
Jake:没有呵呵呵呵
Jake: No, hahaha.
其他人:最高评价
Others: Highest praise.
Jake:蛋挞加奶油
Jake: Egg tart with cream.
其他人:有点像那个东西
Others: It kinda looks like that thing.
Alice:哈哈哈什么东西
Alice: Hahaha, what thing?
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What thing?
Jake:细数细数啊啊
Jake: Count it, count it, ah ah.
其他人:在喷点上面喷点巧克力
Others: Spray some chocolate on top.
Tasha:是的会喷的
Tasha: Yes, it will spray.
其他人:或者提拉米苏就更像
Others: Or Tiramisu, it looks more like it.
Tasha:拿个刮刀能把它抹平吗
Tasha: Can you use a spatula to smooth it out?
Tasha:有没有一个刮刀
Tasha: Is there a spatula?
Alice:我来吧
Alice: Let me do it.
Lucia: 昨天的那个
Lucia: Yesterday's one.
Alice:小刮刀吗
Alice: A small spatula?
Lucia: 这这种的
Lucia: This kind.
Lucia: 这种的哎呦妈呀
Lucia: This kind, oh my.
Lucia: 对这个哎
Lucia: Yeah, this one.
Lucia: 应该有一有一片小的
Lucia: There should be a small piece.
Lucia: 算了就用这个吧
Lucia: Forget it, just use this one.
其他人:这个给我吧
Others: Give it to me.
其他人:既然都已经坏了
Others: Since it's already broken.
Jake:他们都是一样的吗
Jake: Are they all the same?
Alice:那你来吧
Alice: Then you do it.
Jake:还是说就这几个
Jake: Or just these few.
Tasha:白色的啊
Tasha: The white one?
Tasha:对怎么这么大
Tasha: Yeah, why is it so big?
Lucia: 小的那个刚没找着
Lucia: Couldn't find the smaller one just now.
Lucia: 有吗
Lucia: Is there any?
其他人:你这个都
Others: All of yours...
Lucia: 有一个比那小的
Lucia: There's one smaller than that.
Jake:哈哈会动吗
Jake: Haha, does it move?
Lucia: 那天还用了
Lucia: We used it the other day.
Lucia: 但是不知道放哪了
Lucia: But don't know where it is now.
Jake:看你水平了
Jake: Let's see your skills.
Alice:算了找不着好像
Alice: Forget it, seems like we can't find it.
Alice:那有没有
Alice: So, is there any?
其他人:你自己在家做蛋挞吃也是加这么多料
Others: Do you add this much when you make egg tarts at home?
Lucia: 不是这个
Lucia: Not this one.
Jake:拿去卖了
Jake: Take it and sell it.
Alice:是这个吗
Alice: Is it this one?
Jake:这么回事
Jake: That's how it is.
其他人:可以录的吗
Others: Can it be recorded?
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 呃我觉得
Lucia: Uh, I think...
Lucia: 这个也可以用微微那个
Lucia: This can also use the small one.
Lucia: 这种小刀也可以吧
Lucia: This small knife can also work, right?
Lucia: 这个没关系啊
Lucia: It's okay with this.
Jake:就这样吧
Jake: Let's just do it like this.
Lucia: 那就那就用这个吧
Lucia: Then let's just use this one.
Lucia: 就用这个大的也行
Lucia: Using the big one is also fine.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Lucia: 小心
Lucia: Be careful.
其他人:但是水果还没加
Others: But the fruits haven't been added yet.
其他人:这为什么这么稀呀
Others: Why is it so runny?
Tasha:这还稀
Tasha: This is still runny?
Tasha:这这边还有一个
Tasha: There's one more over here.
Lucia: 奶油还有好多
Lucia: There's still a lot of cream.
Alice:太会抹了
Alice: You're so good at spreading it.
Alice:你不会偷偷学过吧
Alice: Did you secretly practice this?
其他人:啊这还会抹
Others: Wow, you can spread it like this?
其他人:这不都瞎抹的
Others: It's all just randomly spread.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:这个应该快没那个存储了
Alice: This is probably running out of storage.
Alice:停吗
Alice: Should we stop?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:看一下呃
Jake: Let me check, uh...
Alice:呃我看我的
Alice: Uh, I'll check mine.
Jake:就等没清楚就停吧
Jake: If it's not clear, let's just stop.
Jake:就是咱也还有
Jake: We still have some left.
Jake:还有还有半个小时
Jake: We still have half an hour.
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay.
其他人：半个小时啊
Others: Half an hour, huh?
Jake:没有就是这一轮
Jake: No, just this round.
Alice:3333
Alice: 3333
Jake:33
Jake: 33
Jake:对啊半个小时
Jake: Yeah, half an hour.
Jake:一个小时40分钟吧
Jake: An hour and 40 minutes, maybe.
Alice:甜品师傅
Alice: Pastry chef.
其他人:刮刮腻子师傅
Others: Plasterer.
Jake:嗯把这换成叉子
Jake: Hmm, let's switch this to a fork.
Lucia: 那个纸在
Lucia: The paper is...
Lucia: 这
Lucia: Here.
Lucia: 那个盘现在要铺上这个油纸吗
Lucia: Do we need to lay this parchment paper on the tray now?
Jake:那就不铺
Jake: Then don't lay it.
Lucia: 他蛋挞底下是有那个没有
Lucia: Is there anything under the egg tarts?
Alice:嗯没有没有
Alice: No, no.
Lucia: 没有啊嗯
Lucia: No, huh? Okay.
Jake:嗯那还是扑一下吧
Jake: Hmm, let's lay it just in case.
Lucia: 因为那个刚拆开
Lucia: Because it's just been opened.
Lucia: 就我刚用纸擦的时候他稍微有点掉色
Lucia: When I wiped it with paper, it slightly discolored.
Lucia: 其实因为他是个新的嘛
Lucia: Actually, because it's new.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 所以要不然咱们安全起见
Lucia: So, for safety's sake...
Jake:那我们稍微扑一扑
Jake: Let's lay it a little.
Jake:稍微扑一扑
Jake: Just a bit.
Jake:小扑一下
Jake: Just a small layer.
Lucia: 我比划比划啊
Lucia: I'll measure it.
其他人:哦我们明天车有多少人我
Others: Oh, how many people do we have in the car tomorrow?
Lucia: 这个宽度好
Lucia: This width is good.
Jake:嗯合适合适的不得了可以
Jake: Hmm, perfect, absolutely perfect.
Lucia: 还行
Lucia: Not bad.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Good.
Lucia: 那就把它撕齐一点
Lucia: Then tear it a little more evenly.
Lucia: 我把这往里拽一拽拽一拽
Lucia: I'll pull this inside a bit, pull it inside.
其他人:他明天不来吗
Others: Is he not coming tomorrow?
Jake:来来来来来
Jake: He is, he is, he is.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你的车是哪来
Jake: Where's your car from?
其他人:他自己的车
Others: It's his own car.
其他人:啊
Others: Ah.
其他人：我靠好高级
Others: Woah, so fancy.
Lucia: 觉得这个长度应该差不多
Lucia: I think this length is about right.
Jake:来请坐
Jake: Come, have a seat.
其他人:我有义有吾有义
Others: I have something, I have something.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Lucia: 咦可恶
Lucia: Ugh, annoying.
Jake:来我来玩
Jake: Let me play.
Lucia: 稍微有点歪
Lucia: It's a bit crooked.
Jake:我要玩嗯玩不了
Jake: I want to play, hmm, can't play.
Tasha:你可以把黄豆粉拿来
Tasha: Can you bring the soy flour?
Jake:土豆粉
Jake: Potato flour.
Alice:黄豆粉
Alice: Soy flour.
Jake:黄豆粉是谁
Jake: Who is soy flour?
其他人：不像蛋挞
Others: Doesn't look like an egg tart.
Lucia: 其他人：
Lucia: Others:
其他人：但确实做的好
Others: But it does look well made.
Lucia: 我感觉左边这个没有撕齐
Lucia: I feel like the left side isn't evenly torn.
Lucia: 要不再重撕一下
Lucia: How about we tear it again?
Alice:这个
Alice: This.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 问题不大
Lucia: It's not a big problem.
Jake:熟黄豆粉刚
Jake: Roasted soy flour just now.
Lucia: 对就这刚才我手一抖摔了
Lucia: Right, just now my hand shook and dropped it.
Alice:你要玩吗
Alice: Do you want to play?
Jake:我要玩啊我要玩
Jake: I want to play, I want to play.
Lucia: 这边这个比较齐
Lucia: This side is more even.
Lucia: 就是就是这个孔对对
Lucia: It's just, just this hole, right.
其他人:卧槽你看
Others: Whoa, look.
其他人:变这么好看了
Others: It turned out so nice.
其他人:对哼
Others: Yeah, right.
Jake:玩手机玩了10分钟
Jake: Played on the phone for 10 minutes.
Jake:变好看了
Jake: It turned out nice.
Tasha:抖就这样抖就可以了
Tasha: Just shake it like this, it's fine.
其他人:变好看了
Others: Looks better now.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Tasha:等等等等
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait.
Tasha:哎呦哎没事没事
Tasha: Oh no, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 哎底下稍微有点湿
Lucia: Oh, it's a bit wet underneath.
Lucia: 没事这个这个纸不剩水可以
Lucia: It's okay, this paper doesn't absorb water, it's fine.
Tasha:没事没事
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 那也行时间长了他会不会透
Lucia: But if it stays for too long, won't it seep through?
Tasha:再抖时间长了才会痛
Tasha: If you shake it for too long, it will hurt.
Lucia: 要不还是拿张纸擦一下过去拿
Lucia: Maybe we should wipe it with a piece of paper.
Tasha:好了吗直接撒我嘴里
Tasha: Is it ready? Just pour it into my mouth.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈炫我嘴里
Lucia: Haha, pour it into my mouth.
Jake:来来来张嘴
Jake: Come on, open your mouth.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈这一一眼睛这是
Jake: Hahaha, oh this is... in the eye.
Tasha:下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Jake:这个还是要什么什么色
Jake: What color does it need to be?
Alice:不弄抹茶的吗
Alice: Aren't we doing matcha?
其他人:我靠高级
Others: Wow, so fancy.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Jake:确实确实厉害
Jake: Indeed, it's impressive.
其他人：非常的厉害
Others: Very impressive.
Alice:可以
Alice: It's good.
Jake:那剩下来怎么办
Jake: What about the leftovers?
Jake:只能倒进嘴里
Jake: We can only pour it into our mouths.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么办啊
Jake: Haha, what should we do?
Jake:这个倒掉这个倒掉
Jake: Pour it out, pour it out.
Jake:那好吧倒这里倒这里
Jake: Alright, pour it here, pour it here.
Lucia: 我嘴里
Lucia: Into my mouth.
Jake:倒真的哈哈哈好
Jake: Pour it, really? Haha, alright.
Lucia: 哈哈哈那个没法炫我嘴里
Lucia: Haha, you can't pour it into my mouth like that.
Lucia: 会炫我脸上
Lucia: It will splash on my face.
Jake:那我现在鼠标上吧
Jake: Then I'll pour it on the mouse.
其他人：抹茶粉吗
Others: Matcha powder?
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 抹茶粉太贵了
Lucia: Matcha powder is too expensive.
Tasha:所以我不舍得这样子倒
Tasha: That's why I can't bear to pour it like that.
其他人:抹茶粉太贵了嗯
Others: Matcha powder is too expensive, yeah.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:槽可以不用了
Jake: We don't need the slot anymore.
Jake:真的那我再多擦点
Jake: Really? Then I'll wipe some more.
Tasha:我靠真的好吃
Tasha: Wow, this is really delicious.
Alice:什么好吃
Alice: What's delicious?
其他人：好吃没味
Others: Delicious but flavorless.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈跟没家一样
Jake: Hahaha, it's like there's nothing added.
Alice:好吃美味
Alice: Delicious and flavorful.
Lucia: 跟没加一样跟没加一样
Lucia: It's like there's nothing added, just like nothing added.
其他人：跟没加一样
Others: Just like nothing added.
Jake:这是最高评价吗哈哈哈
Jake: Is this the highest praise? Hahaha.
Alice:好吧
Alice: Alright then.
Jake:抹茶粉多贵啊
Jake: Matcha powder is so expensive.
Lucia: 左边这跟右边那不一样大
Lucia: The left side and the right side aren't the same size.
Tasha:呃一克一克两块钱
Tasha: Uh, one gram is two yuan.
Lucia: 我好想给他换一下
Lucia: I really want to switch it.
Jake:我去一克两块钱
Jake: Wow, one gram is two yuan.
其他人：一克两块钱
Others: One gram is two yuan.
其他人：那还比黄金便宜
Others: That's cheaper than gold.
Lucia: 南北黄金便宜点
Lucia: Gold in the south is cheaper.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈那便宜好多
Jake: Hahaha, that's much cheaper.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha:那便宜好多
Tasha: That's much cheaper.
Lucia: 这空了可以扔
Lucia: This is empty, you can throw it away.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
其他人：哎那个怎么有一些奶油
Others: Hey, why is there some cream here?
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's fine, it's fine.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha:边角料全部都炫掉
Tasha: Use up all the scraps.
Tasha:哎嗯
Tasha: Hey, hmm.
Jake:还没撒粉呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled the powder yet.
Jake:嗯那个对
Jake: Hmm, that one, yeah.
Tasha:嗯就就一直在洒
Tasha: Hmm, just keep sprinkling it.
Lucia: 已经拿起来了
Lucia: It's already picked up.
Jake:黄金还没撒呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled the gold yet.
Jake:小黄金
Jake: Little gold.
其他人:我靠那一会没撒完
Others: Wow, it won't be fully sprinkled later.
其他人:抹茶粉可以炫耀谁
Others: Who can show off the matcha powder?
其他人:我很喜欢的
Others: I really like it.
Jake:好嘞好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 这个抹茶饭挺好吃的牛逼
Tasha: This matcha rice is pretty good, awesome!
其他人：牛逼
Others: Awesome!
Tasha:好撒吧呵呵
Tasha: Okay, let's sprinkle it, haha.
其他人：这个也经常倒这么一点撒
Others: Yeah, we usually just sprinkle a little bit like this.
Tasha:呃洗四颗草莓
其他人:这是
Others: This is...
其他人:这是有排版的呀
Others: This has a layout!
其他人:我靠
Others: Wow!
其他人:非常的高级
Others: Very fancy!
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个上面要放草莓
Others: Why is there one with 6 and one with 5 strawberries on top?
Tasha:对
Tasha: Right.
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个
Others: Why is there one with 6 and one with 5?
Tasha:被他偷走了一个
Tasha: Someone stole one.
其他人：这个确实不错
Others: This is indeed good.
Jake:其他人:
Jake: Others:
其他人:那我再偷吃一个可乐
Others: Then I'll steal another one, Cola.
其他人：我再偷吃一个
Others: I'll steal another one.
Lucia: 你想吃哪个
Lucia: Which one do you want to eat?
其他人:你让我吃哪个
Others: Which one do you want me to eat?
Lucia: 你想吃哪个吃哪个
Lucia: Eat whichever you want.
Lucia: 偷吃这个饭
Lucia: Steal this rice.
Lucia: 偷吃这个
Lucia: Steal this one.
Alice:还要再来一点
Alice: I want a little more.
Jake:还要还要还来点来点
Jake: More, more, give me more.
Alice:切不切
Alice: Should we cut it?
Tasha:不切
Tasha: No.
Katrina: 我之前我第一个是在杭州线下买的
Katrina: The first one I bought was offline in Hangzhou.
Katrina: 我买的是
Katrina: I bought it...
Jake:哎呀这个挪一挪
Jake: Oh, let's move this.
Katrina: 线下门店
Katrina: Offline store.
Katrina: 只有几个城市有
Katrina: Only a few cities have it.
Katrina: 嗯北京国贸也有
Katrina: Yeah, Beijing's World Trade Center has it too.
Katrina: 我想想对他我一共有几个
Katrina: Let me think, yeah, I have a few of them.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 不脱手了
Katrina: Not giving it up.
Katrina: 我买了
Katrina: I bought it.
Katrina: 这个你看他们都属于一个系列的
Katrina: You see, they're all part of a series.
Katrina: 叫什么波
Katrina: Called Bo...
Tasha:我的天呐
Tasha: Oh my god
Jake:哦好吸
Jake: Oh, that's very smooth
Katrina: 我之前买了这个
Katrina: I bought this before
其他人：确实这个奶油为啥这么稀
Others: Indeed, why is this cream so thin?
Tasha:因为本来是吸的
Tasha: Because it's supposed to be thin
Tasha:但是这个蛋挞太热了给它融了
Tasha: But this egg tart is too hot, it melted it
Alice:给它融了
Alice: It melted it
Jake:哦好好好好好交错
Jake: Oh, okay, okay, okay, just alternate
其他人：你交错着放
Others: You alternate them
Katrina: 这很这很舒服
Katrina: This feels very comfortable
Katrina: 这跟这一个系列的
Katrina: This is part of this series
Tasha:快吃快吃
Tasha: Quick, eat, eat
Tasha:别拍了
Tasha: Stop filming
Tasha:大家快吃
Tasha: Everyone, eat quickly
其他人：找了半天角落没有找到合适的
Others: We searched everywhere but couldn't find a suitable corner
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay
其他人：太久了
Others: Took too long
Tasha:快吃
Tasha: Hurry up and eat
Jake:我每天都在这种surprising中
Jake: I'm surprised every day
Alice:等我一下
Alice: Wait for me
Jake:来吃吃吃
Jake: Come on, eat, eat, eat
Lucia: 好好看啊吃吃吃
Lucia: It looks so good, let's eat
Jake:大师您先吃您先吃
Jake: Master, you eat first, you go ahead
Tasha:您先吃
Tasha: You eat first
Jake:您先吃下一个
Jake: You go first, next one
Jake:哈哈哎
Jake: Haha, hey
Tasha:哎这个真的擦了吗
Tasha: Hey, did you really wipe this?
Lucia: 擦了但是他那个渣就会粘在上面
Lucia: Wiped, but the crumbs will stick on it
Lucia: 就是厨房纸会被他那个木头
Lucia: The kitchen paper gets stuck on the wood
Lucia: 挂掉
Lucia: It gets caught
Tasha:嗯嗯嗯
Tasha: Mm, mm, mm
Lucia: 所以我那那里面也垫一个
Lucia: So I also put one inside
Lucia: 等一下我刚哎刚那个
Lucia: Wait, I just, hey, just
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This
其他人：你不会还留着吧
Others: You didn't keep it, did you?
Lucia: 呃呃这个要垫一下吗还是
Lucia: Uh, should I put something underneath or
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Lucia: 那就垫一下吧
Lucia: Then just put something underneath
Katrina: 这个这个细
Katrina: This, this is fine
Katrina: 这个很细哦
Katrina: This is very fine
Lucia: 因为我擦的时候
Lucia: Because when I was wiping it,
Lucia: 感觉他真的有点有点掉色
Lucia: I felt like it was really fading a bit.
Katrina: 这个很舒服
Katrina: This feels so comfortable.
其他人:傻逼企鹅狗都别买
Others: Don't buy any stupid penguin stuff.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
其他人:没事我买这个
Others: It's okay, I'll buy this one.
其他人:就是我女朋友的前男友
Others: It's my girlfriend's ex-boyfriend.
其他人:送我女朋友的是企鹅
Others: He gave my girlfriend a penguin.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅啊
Others: He gave his ex-boyfriend a penguin.
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅哦
Others: He gave his ex-boyfriend a penguin, yeah.
Jake:然后
Jake: And then?
其他人:我女朋友的前男友送我女朋友的
Others: My girlfriend's ex-boyfriend gave her...
其他人:也是企鹅
Others: Also a penguin.
Katrina: 就是他被绿的那个
Katrina: He got cheated on.
其他人:不是不是不是我现在的女朋友
Others: No, no, not my current girlfriend.
Katrina: 你现任女朋友的前男友哦
Katrina: Your current girlfriend's ex-boyfriend.
其他人:你天呐
Others: Oh my god.
其他人：这个要怎么放
Others: How do you place this?
Jake:建立了连接
Jake: Connection established.
Lucia: 就这样应该就可以了
Lucia: It should be fine like this.
Jake:collected
Jake: Collected.
Lucia: 就稍微垫一下
Lucia: Just pad it a bit.
Lucia: 因为怕他怕他掉色
Lucia: Because I'm afraid it might fade.
Jake:好吃
Jake: Delicious.
其他人:好我立马辞职
Others: Alright, I'll resign immediately.
其他人:为了你我加入自己哈哈哈
Others: For you, I'll join myself, haha.
Katrina: 这种这种就是库存就几个的
Katrina: This kind, there are only a few in stock.
Katrina: 就一般是个人海淘
Katrina: Usually, it's personal overseas purchase.
Jake:我先把这个收了吧
Jake: I'll collect this first.
Katrina: 就是他们从官网下单
Katrina: They order from the official website.
Katrina: 然后要等一个月什么的
Katrina: Then wait for a month or something.
Katrina: 然后这种的话就比较真
Katrina: And this kind is more genuine.
Jake:我靠这很难很难
Jake: Damn, this is really difficult.
Lucia: 哦他也塌了
Lucia: Oh, it collapsed too.
Lucia: 蛋挞太热了
Lucia: The egg tart is too hot.
Katrina: 要么就官网买
Katrina: Or buy from the official website.
Katrina: 官网经常没货
Katrina: The official website is often out of stock.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: 这么大
Katrina: This big?
Katrina: 那就别送企鹅
Katrina: Then don't send the penguin.
其他人：不是说买这个
Others: Didn't you say to buy this?
其他人：对对对这个是正确的
Others: Yes, yes, this is correct.
Jake:我看看
Jake: Let me see.
Katrina: 非常的好
Katrina: It's really good.
其他人：非常的好看啊
Others: It's really nice.
Jake:这是狐狸对
Jake: This is a fox, right?
其他人：对我给你找找感觉
Others: Yes, I'll help you find the feeling.
Katrina: 我给你找找感觉
Katrina: I'll help you find the feeling.
Katrina: 居然吗断货吗
Katrina: Seriously, it's out of stock?
Katrina: 这狐狸这狐狸有点丑
Katrina: This fox, this fox is kind of ugly.
Alice:可爱你
Alice: Love you.
Tasha:用一个容器
Tasha: Use a container.
Jake:容器
Jake: Container.
Jake:真圆
Jake: So round.
Katrina: 京东上倒有369
Katrina: There's 369 on JD.
Katrina: 有点过分了
Katrina: That's a bit much.
Katrina: 他怎么溢价呢还有217
Katrina: How come it's overpriced? It's still 217.
Tasha:咖啡液咖啡液
Tasha: Coffee liquid, coffee liquid.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:在这
Alice: It's here.
其他人：这还要用咖啡液
Others: You need coffee liquid for this?
Katrina: 这我不太知道
Katrina: I'm not really sure about this.
Katrina: 京东这个是个人买件还是什么
Katrina: Is this JD purchase personal or what?
Alice:提拉米不要用啊
Alice: Tiramisu doesn't use it.
其他人：我说我直接这么切吧
Others: I think I should just cut it like this.
Katrina: 害怕你被坑了
Katrina: Afraid you might get scammed.
Tasha:你切
Tasha: You cut it.
Tasha:但是你可以用那个切刀洗咖啡液
Tasha: But you can use that cutter to wash the coffee liquid.
Alice:咖啡液
Alice: Coffee liquid.
Lucia:  是那天那个刀吗
Lucia: Is it that knife from the other day?
Katrina: 那这个怎么判断呢
Katrina: How do you determine this?
Jake:切切刀
Jake: Cutting knife.
Jake:切刀是什么
Jake: What's a cutting knife?
Lucia: 那天那天杨老板切蛋糕那个刀吗
Lucia: Is it the knife Jake used to cut the cake the other day?
Tasha:对对
Tasha: Yes, yes.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Tasha:你用这个也行
Tasha: You can use this too.
Jake:看到咖啡叶
Jake: I see the coffee leaves.
Jake:咖啡叶
Jake: Coffee leaves
Jake:这个吗
Jake: This one?
Tasha:嗯也可以
Tasha: Yeah, it works.
Lucia: 咖啡液
Lucia: Coffee liquid
Lucia: 是咱们那天那个绿色的那个吗
Lucia: Is it the green one we had the other day?
Lucia: 就是这也行啊
Lucia: This one works too.
Katrina: 的
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:瑞幸咖啡业
Jake: Luckin Coffee.
Lucia: 瑞幸咖啡叶拆一下
Lucia: Unpack the Luckin Coffee leaves.
Alice:冷萃的
Alice: Cold brew.
Jake:都不知道为什么出现在这
Jake: I don't even know why it's here.
Jake:不知道怎么是怎么就买了呢
Jake: No idea why we bought it.
Alice:太讲究了
Alice: So fancy.
Lucia: 他突然就出现在了需要用的地方
Lucia: It just appeared when we needed it.
Lucia: 很好
Lucia: Perfect.
其他人：我操
Others: Damn.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Whoa.
Alice:怪会摆的
Alice: Quite impressive.
Jake:怎么怎么怎么买
Jake: How did we buy this?
Katrina: 这不可能只有149
Katrina: This can't be just 149.
Jake:这个200多块钱
Jake: This is over 200 bucks.
Katrina: 这个200多块钱
Katrina: This is over 200 bucks.
Jake:判断什么
Jake: What do you think?
Katrina: 而且会而且会有溢价
Katrina: Plus, it might have a premium.
其他人:他就看库存就能看出来
Others: Just look at the stock.
其他人:这个东西他觉得真不真哦
Others: You can tell if it's real.
其他人:哎这还都响
Others: Oh, it still works.
Jake:对新乐器
Jake: Yes, it's a new instrument.
Lucia: 哇好开了
Lucia: Wow, it opened well.
Tasha:拿一个
Tasha: Take one.
Katrina: 但是一家也没必要
Katrina: But there's no need for a whole set.
Alice: 25毫升还要多少
Alice: 25 ml is enough, right?
Katrina: 你你着急送人吗
Katrina: Are you in a hurry to gift it?
Katrina: 孩子那也不太急
Katrina: The kid isn't that urgent.
Tasha:呃 25毫升刚刚好哦
Tasha: Uh, 25 ml is just right.
Katrina: 送女生那确实
Katrina: For gifting a girl, yeah.
其他人:确实哦这个咖啡业买还派上用场
Others: Indeed, this coffee purchase was useful.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:呵呵板砖的是吧
Jake: Haha, it's just a brick, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 本来是想加点私货的是吧
Lucia: You were planning to sneak in some extra stuff, right?
其他人：本来是想稍稍加点私货的
Others: You were planning to sneak in a little extra stuff.
Katrina: 找找我的洗钥匙
Katrina: Looking for my keys.
Katrina: 我的小狐狸
Katrina: My little fox.
Alice:等一下等一下
Alice: Wait, wait.
Alice:我靠居然买了一家奶酪
Alice: Oh my, I actually bought a whole cheese.
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 其实那个奶酪也是我家带的死货
Lucia: Actually, that cheese was also something from my place.
Lucia: 不过反正也吃上了哈哈
Lucia: But anyway, we're eating it now, haha.
Katrina: 我靠还没拍照
Katrina: Oh my, we haven't taken a photo yet.
其他人:我靠这摆盘有点怎么怎么
Others: Oh my, this plating looks a bit...
其他人:又低了一下头就已经摆完了
Others: I looked down for a second and it's already done.
其他人:我操你吃完了
Others: Damn, you already finished eating.
Jake:又低了一下头
Jake: I just looked down for a second.
其他人:放上去放上去
Others: Put it on, put it on.
其他人：等等等没摆好
Others: Wait, wait, it's not set properly.
其他人: 放上去
Others: Put it on.
Katrina: 这今天晚上吃的
Katrina: Are we eating this tonight?
Katrina: 还是明天的
Katrina: Or tomorrow?
Tasha:要热水热水热水热水
Tasha: Need hot water, hot water, hot water.
Lucia: 摆热水呃那现在现场烧一个
Lucia: Oh, set up hot water. Uh, let's boil some now.
Jake:这一会再撒撒肉松
Jake: We'll sprinkle some pork floss on it later.
Alice:热水壶在那呢
Alice: The hot water kettle is over there.
Lucia: 热水壶是不俩都在楼上啊
Lucia: Aren't both kettles upstairs?
Lucia: 我去拿吧
Lucia: I'll go get it.
Alice:他他脚那
Alice: It's by his feet.
Alice:这个这个这桌子底下
Alice: It's, it's under the table.
Lucia: 啊楼下有吗
Lucia: Oh, is there one downstairs?
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Tasha:为什么要把他们强行塞在一起
Tasha: Why are you forcing them together?
Jake:方便拍照
Jake: For the photo.
Jake:咱还有道具呢
Jake: We still have props.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:在后面再摆一个显得很多
Jake: Put another one at the back to make it look more.
Alice:你你能不能把这个汇源果汁挡一下
Alice: Can you, can you block that Huiyuan juice?
Jake:我们有整整两大盆
Jake: We have two whole big bowls.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:就这样
Alice: Just like this.
Alice:勤劳
Alice: Diligent.
Lucia: 嗯嗯嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm
Jake:现在还有什
Jake: So now, what else
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else is there
Jake:提拉米苏
Jake: Tiramisu
Lucia: 要用哪个盒子呀
Lucia: Which box should we use?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Lucia: 垫纸吗用这
Lucia: Should we use paper liners?
Lucia: 用这个盒吗还是
Lucia: Should we use this box, or
Alice:用那个就行吧
Alice: That one should be fine.
Lucia: 把这俩挪到一个上
Lucia: Move these two onto one.
其他人：这盒也留下了
Others: This box is also left behind.
Jake:对这个先洗洗
Jake: Yeah, let's wash this one first.
Jake:都是买的
Jake: It's all bought.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:这玩意咋洗
Jake: How do you wash this thing?
Jake:刚刚路亚怎么洗
Jake: How did Luya just wash it?
Jake:就擦了擦是吧
Jake: Just wiped it, right?
Lucia: 我拿这个擦的就是沾点水擦
Lucia: I wiped it with this, just a bit of water.
Lucia: 但是就是因为这是木头的
Lucia: But since it's wood,
Lucia: 所以他就是上面的有可能会有刺
Lucia: it might have some splinters on the surface.
Jake:可能得
Jake: Might need to
Lucia: 会把这个稍微刮下来
Lucia: scrape it off a bit.
Tasha:热水好了给我一下热水好了给我一下
Tasha: The hot water is ready, can you give it to me?
Jake:换几张纸
Jake: Change a few sheets of paper.
Lucia: 直接
Lucia: Just
Jake:那厨那那厨房纸有用吗
Jake: Will kitchen paper work?
Lucia: 呃那个好像不能直接用
Lucia: Uh, it seems like we can't use it directly.
Lucia: 就是上面不是有那个洗洁精吗
Lucia: Because it has dish soap on it.
Lucia: 如果你直接擦好就会留在上面
Lucia: If you wipe it directly, it'll stay on it.
Lucia: 或者能直接洗一下可能也行
Lucia: Or we could just wash it directly, that might work too.
Jake:那我过水了
Jake: Then I'll rinse it.
Jake:行我觉得我直接洗一洗
Jake: Okay, I think I'll just wash it.
Lucia: 用这个也洗一下吧
Lucia: Let's wash this one too.
Tasha:完了这个盆放不下
Tasha: Oh no, this basin doesn't fit.
Tasha:有没有放个大点的盆给我
Tasha: Do we have a bigger basin?
Lucia: 盆盘
Lucia: Basin, plate.
Tasha:盆盆盆
Tasha: Basin, basin, basin.
Lucia: 等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a second.
Jake:那个大碗是吧哦挺好
Jake: That big bowl, right? Oh, that's good.
Lucia: 那个盘哎
Lucia: That plate, hey.
Lucia: 这个有没有更大一点
Lucia: Is there a bigger one?
Lucia: 或者
Lucia: Or...
Jake:就这个就
Jake: This one will do.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: How about this one?
Lucia: 这个不太行
Lucia: This one isn't quite right.
Jake:好这边可以
Jake: Okay, this one works.
Alice:这个或者这个这个吧
Alice: This one or maybe this one.
Alice:这个底深
Alice: This one has a deeper bottom.
Lucia: 这有俩不过这俩应该是一样大的
Lucia: There are two here, but they should be the same size.
Alice:用这个吧
Alice: Let's use this one.
Lucia: 哦那个碗
Lucia: Oh, that bowl.
Lucia: 对那碗能盛的更深一点
Lucia: Yeah, that bowl can hold more.
Alice:我再涮一下吧
Alice: I'll rinse this again.
Lucia: 这是什么
Lucia: What's this?
Lucia: 红糖出来了
Lucia: The brown sugar is out.
Lucia: 酒咖啡
Lucia: Wine coffee.
Jake:戴眼镜吧
Jake: Wear glasses.
Alice:手指饼干呢
Alice: Where are the ladyfingers?
Lucia: 这要擦一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to wipe this?
Lucia: 拿出来了
Lucia: It's out.
Lucia: 手指饼干
Lucia: Ladyfingers.
Tasha:不用了不用了哦
Tasha: No need, no need.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
其他人:一下蘸
Others: Dip it quickly.
Alice:不是蘸一下咖啡
Alice: Just dip it in the coffee.
其他人:一下咖啡蘸一下那个蘸一下咖啡
Others: Dip it in the coffee, dip it quickly.
Alice:蘸一下那个
Alice: Just dip it.
Alice:没事等一会吧
Alice: Never mind, let's wait a bit.
其他人:然后我
Others: Then I...
Alice:烤啊不烤就直接放那
Alice: Bake it or just put it there directly.
Lucia: 我来没事
Lucia: I'll do it, no worries.
Alice:蘸一下然后放在那个夹层里
Alice: Dip it and then put it in the layer.
Shure: 外面是不是有点小冷
Shure: Is it a bit cold outside?
Shure: 谁开的 16度
Shure: Who set it to 16 degrees?
Tasha:没了
Tasha: It's not working.
Jake:京爷京爷这就是京爷
Jake: Jingye, Jingye, this is Jingye.
Shure: 你在家不挨揍吗
Shure: Don't you get beaten at home?
Jake:京爷
Jake: Jingye.
Alice:你是突然出现的吗
Alice: Did you just appear out of nowhere?
Alice:刚刚你在这吗
Alice: Were you here just now?
Shure: 我刚不在这
Shure: I wasn't here just now.
Shure: 我刚开会
Shure: I was in a meeting.
Shure: 牛排呢吃没了都
Shure: Where's the steak? It's all gone.
Alice:啊
Alice: Huh?
Shure: 牛排吃没了
Shure: The steak is all gone.
Jake:我靠为什么哦
Jake: What the heck, why?
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Jake:26了都行
Jake: It's already 26, that's okay.
Tasha:这个咖啡
Tasha: This coffee...
Alice:这个这个咖啡咖啡液奥
Alice: This, this coffee liquid.
其他人：提拉米苏是
Others: Tiramisu is...
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 手指饼干
Tasha: Ladyfingers.
Jake:哦想吃了已经
Jake: Oh, I already want to eat them.
其他人：哇好高级
Others: Wow, so fancy.
Tasha:哎你这样放太多了
Tasha: Hey, you put too much.
Alice:太快了
Alice: Too fast.
Tasha:这饼干全部都不能要了
Tasha: These cookies can't be used now.
Alice:哎呀不行了
Alice: Oh no, it won't work.
其他人:没事没事我这还有几个
Others: It's okay, it's okay, I have a few more here.
Tasha:呃这几个都不能要了哦
Tasha: Uh, these few can't be used either.
其他人：哦它已经软了是吧
Others: Oh, they've already gone soft, right?
Alice:对对我来吧
Alice: Yes, yes, let me do it.
Lucia: 拿个勺把它舀出来
Lucia: Use a spoon to scoop it out.
Tasha:这几个把咖啡液全部都吸走了
Tasha: These few absorbed all the coffee liquid.
Shure: 哎呀哎呀哎呀
Shure: Oh no, oh no, oh no.
Jake:没事你先吃了吧要不
Jake: It's okay, you can eat it first.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha:继续搁吧
Tasha: Keep adding it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 那几个要不要弄一下
Lucia: Do you want to do something with those?
Lucia: 还是放那就行那行
Lucia: Or just leave them there, that's fine too.
Jake:咸鸭蛋
Jake: Salted duck egg.
Shure: 吃过吧小伙伴
Shure: Have you guys tried it?
Jake:吃还是常吃
Jake: Tried it, eat it often.
其他人：要不再弄个咖啡
Others: Shall we make another coffee?
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
Tasha: 不够了对
Tasha: It’s not enough, right?
Tasha:要重新弄可能
Tasha: We might need to redo it.
其他人:没事没事还有那个
Others: No worries, we still have that.
其他人:算了不行我还给你手穿了
Others: Never mind, it won't work, I’ll give you a hand.
Shure: 不行我还可以首充
Shure: No, I can still recharge.
Tasha:搁
Tasha: Got it.
其他人:然后再来一盘就能吃了
Others: Then one more round and it’ll be ready to eat.
Tasha:对
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha:还要再来一盘
Tasha: We need one more round.
Tasha:就就这些
Tasha: That's it.
其他人:没有没有
Others: No, no.
其他人:那还有一包
Others: There's still one pack left.
Lucia: 这个可以先放回去
Lucia: We can put this back for now.
Lucia: 要把它舀出来用着吃
Lucia: Scoop it out to eat.
其他人：对一会给大家吃了
Others: Yeah, everyone can have some later.
其他人：行你要单吃一个尝尝
Others: Sure, do you want to try one alone?
其他人:这上面不是撒了一层糖吗
Others: Isn’t there a layer of sugar on top?
其他人:为什么这个有菠萝味啊
Others: Why does this one taste like pineapple?
Alice:里面放菠萝了
Alice: There's pineapple inside.
Lucia: 有菠萝夹心
Lucia: There's pineapple filling.
其他人:我放菠萝
Others: I'll add pineapple.
Alice:夹带了
Alice: It's already added.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
其他人：要是没有就更好
Others: It would be better without it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈要是没有了上面没有
Lucia: Hahaha, it would be better without it on top.
Tasha:上面上面有没有的
Tasha: Is there any on top?
Tasha:上面没有
Tasha: There's none on top.
Lucia: 要是没有就更
Lucia: It would be better without it.
Jake:我也整一个
Jake: I'll make one too.
Tasha:你失败了
Tasha: You failed.
Tasha:刘帅受到了大家的批评
Tasha: Choiszt got criticized by everyone.
其他人：就一个人批评
Others: Only one person criticized.
Jake:对我这个
Jake: Yeah, I...
Jake:来表扬一下
Jake: Let's give some praise.
Jake:这有没有菠萝
Jake: Is there pineapple in this?
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Jake:不一定没有
Jake: Maybe there isn't.
Jake:这这有菠萝吗
Jake: Is there pineapple in this?
Alice:这个没有
Alice: This one doesn't have any.
其他人：底下那个有吗
Others: Is there any at the bottom?
Tasha:没有了你看你要是不拿走刚刚好
Tasha: There's nothing left, see, if you hadn't taken it, it would have been just right.
其他人：那把这个挤一下
Others: Then squeeze this a bit.
其他人:就是拿手上捏
Others: Just hold it and pinch.
Tasha: 怎么挤
Tasha: How do I squeeze it?
Tasha: 谁来捏
Tasha: Who's going to pinch it?
其他人：像那个抹布一样
Others: Like a rag.
Lucia: 不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
其他人:也可以来几个
Others: You can try a few.
其他人:没有提拉米苏味的或者其他味的
Others: Maybe not tiramisu flavor, or other flavors.
其他人:抹茶味的
Others: Matcha flavor.
Tasha:怎么样都是需要手指饼干的
Tasha: Anyway, we need ladyfingers.
其他人:或者可乐味
Others: Or cola flavor.
Shure: 好吃吗这是咸鸭蛋
Shure: Is it tasty? This is salted duck egg.
Jake:每追回一台
Jake: Each one we retrieve.
其他人：其实还是有
Others: Actually, there still are.
Jake:你听说过高油咸鸭蛋吗
Jake: Have you heard of high-oil salted duck eggs?
Shure: 听说过
Shure: I've heard of them.
其他人：这不是汪曾祺的
Others: Isn't that from Wang Zengqi?
其他人:小说嘛嗯
Others: The novel, right?
其他人:非常的真的吗
Others: Really? Seriously?
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
其他人:好吃嗯
Others: Tasty, yeah.
Shure: 真的是王胜奇的小说吗
Shure: Is it really from Wang Shengqi's novel?
其他人:好像是个高油鸭蛋
Others: Seems like it's a high-oil duck egg.
Shure: 我是个仗义
Shure: I'm a righteous person.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
其他人:我也不知道
Others: I don't know either.
其他人:我只是撕
Others: I'm just tearing.
其他人:要捏一个嘛
Others: Got to pinch one.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha:不知道该怎么办
Tasha: I don't know what to do.
其他人：没事少一个也无所谓
Others: It's okay, it's no big deal if we're missing one.
Alice:你把这个搁这这底下这个
Alice: Put this here, this bottom part.
其他人：这么多咱都吃不了
Others: There's so much, we can't eat it all.
其他人：来一个尝尝
Others: Try one.
其他人：你尝尝
Others: You try it.
其他人:好吃的吃这个你也吃
Others: It's delicious, have some, you too.
Shure: 牛排怎么这么受欢迎呢
Shure: Why is the steak so popular?
Jake:是直接吃吗
Jake: Do you eat it directly?
Jake:啊饱了和和和会吧
Jake: Ah, full and full, right?
Shure: 我出来都没了
Shure: I came out and it's all gone.
Jake:休息一下休息一下
Jake: Take a break, take a break.
Shure: 我吃了个饺子
Shure: I had a dumpling.
其他人:这奶油吗
Others: Is this cream?
Alice:这是
Alice: It is.
其他人:是这是什么东西
Others: What is this?
Jake:提拉米苏啊
Jake: It's tiramisu.
Alice:嗯这个
Alice: Yeah, this.
其他人：这个这个
Others: This, this.
其他人:提拉米苏
Others: Tiramisu.
其他人： 我印象中的提拉米苏怎么是底下那个
Others: The tiramisu I remember has the bottom part.
Tasha:这个先不加
Tasha: Don't add this yet.
其他人：怎么是方
Others: Why is it square?
其他人：方正正的还没切呢
Others: It's square and hasn't been cut yet.
Jake:他可能烤完之后就是方方正正的
Jake: Maybe after baking it, it becomes square.
Tasha:还没切呢
Tasha: It hasn't been cut yet.
Alice:有没有可能等会切一下就是了
Alice: Maybe we can cut it later.
Alice:这不加
Alice: Don't add this.
Tasha: 还是要再来一层
Tasha: We still need another layer.
Jake:他烤完之后他就变成了一层又一层
Jake: After baking, it turns into layer upon layer.
Tasha:拇指饼干没了
Tasha: We're out of ladyfingers.
Tasha: 没就一包
Tasha: Only had one pack.
Alice:还有一包呢
Alice: There's another pack.
其他人：就就这么多
Others: That's all we have.
Alice:还有一包呢
Alice: There's another pack.
其他人：这一层大家都吃不了
Others: This layer can't be finished by everyone.
Tasha:再来再来再来调一层
Tasha: Let's make another layer.
Jake:我骑一会马
Jake: I'll ride a horse for a while.
其他人:我得亏我得亏
Others: I'm so lucky.
Tasha:再来调一层
Tasha: Let's make another layer.
其他人:抖音买了个打火机
Others: Bought a lighter on Douyin.
Lucia: 咖啡
Lucia: Coffee.
Lucia: 就4块嗯
Lucia: It's just 4 bucks.
Shure: 梦里梦到醒不来的梦黑暗里被软禁的
Shure: Dreaming of a dream you can't wake up from, imprisoned in the dark.
Lucia: 哎呦哇没崩到水吧
Lucia: Oh no, did it spill into the water?
Tasha:没事没事没事
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine.
Tasha:还差200克热水
Tasha: Still need 200 grams of hot water.
Tasha:再烧200克
Tasha: Boil another 200 grams.
Jake:师傅没开机啊
Jake: The master didn't turn it on.
Jake:大师啊
Jake: Master!
Jake:眼睛怎么再再整一下
Jake: How about we fix the eyes a bit more?
Jake:再给人再给人整一下
Jake: Let's fix it a bit more for people.
Tasha:糖
Tasha: Sugar.
Tasha:烧20克就行了
Tasha: Just burn 20 grams.
Alice:200
Alice: 200.
Tasha:你加的越多烧的越慢
Tasha: The more you add, the slower it burns.
Lucia: 少倒倒掉点
Lucia: Pour out a bit less.
其他人:那其实如果你这个都泡了以后泡的话
Others: Actually, if you soak all of this...
其他人:就刚才那点那几个饼干也应该加进去
Others: You should add those few biscuits we mentioned earlier.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
其他人:就也可以加进去先烤开了
Others: You can add them and bake it first.
Alice:你抄底的时候可能拖不住要点
Alice: When you scrape the bottom, it might not hold.
其他人:但是你现在加完了以后
Others: But after you add it now...
其他人:他底下不也没泡了
Others: It’s not soaked at the bottom.
Shure: 我的可乐呢
Shure: Where's my Coke?
其他人:就你现在加完这个
Others: After you add this...
其他人:这不也稀的吗
Others: Isn't it diluted?
其他人:那你底下那种那边有个空盒
Others: There's an empty box over there.
Jake:那没人喝的可乐你喝没事还会冷藏
Jake: No one's drinking the Coke, it's fine, it'll be refrigerated.
Alice:啊没事还会冷藏
Alice: Ah, it’ll be refrigerated, no problem.
Jake:这里头
Jake: In here.
Katrina: 录到了
Katrina: Got it recorded.
Shure: 哎卧槽
Shure: Oh, damn.
Shure: 我的尾巴夹住了
Shure: My tail got stuck.
Lucia: 等待烧水
Lucia: Waiting for the water to boil.
Tasha:谁摔了没事
Tasha: Who fell? It's fine.
Shure: 你的你的眼镜没电了
Shure: Your glasses ran out of battery.
Lucia: 不行
Lucia: No way.
Jake:我嗯
Jake: I, uh...
Shure: 可能是你的脸突然把它爆内存了
Shure: Maybe your face overloaded the memory.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:插根插插电吧
Jake: Plug it in.
Jake:应该还是有
Jake: It should still work.
Lucia: excuse me
Lucia: Excuse me.
Tasha:还没有连上吧
Tasha: Haven’t connected yet, right?
Shure: 我们是不是没有排练歌曲啊家人们
Shure: Did we not rehearse the song, guys?
Alice:是这样的
Alice: That’s right.
Jake:这即兴唱呗啊
Jake: Let's just improvise then.
Alice:QA也没有准备吧
Alice: We didn't prepare the Q&A either.
Shure: 啊哈哈哈
Shure: Ah hahaha.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Alice:还有QA
Alice: And there's QA
Shure: 哦QA也没做
Shure: Oh, we haven't done QA either
Alice:QA
Alice: QA
Jake:做一个呗
Jake: Let's do one
Alice:还有藏币
Alice: And there's also the hidden coins
Jake:藏币现藏币
Jake: Hidden coins, show the hidden coins
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Jake:大家大大伙
Jake: Everyone, everyone
Jake:大伙先藏币吧
Jake: Everyone, let's hide the coins first
Jake:币呢币在这这
Jake: Coins, here, here
Alice:币呢
Alice: Where are the coins
Shure: 呢
Shure: Where
Jake:是是是是是币吗
Jake: Is, is, is this the coin
Alice:这是币吗
Alice: Is this the coin
Lucia: 实际上我屋甚至还没整理
Lucia: Actually, my room is not even organized yet
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, it's not
Alice:还没装修呢哈哈
Alice: It's not even decorated yet, haha
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah
Lucia: 每天都有好多事
Lucia: There's so much to do every day
Katrina: 我也变屁了
Katrina: I'm exhausted too
Katrina: 你别问了
Katrina: Don't ask
Jake:那工人怎么
Jake: What about the workers
Jake:咱怎么办
Jake: What should we do
Jake:工人已经救不了了是吧
Jake: The workers can't be saved, right
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:工人哈哈哈
Jake: The workers, hahaha
Katrina: 场面有点失控
Katrina: The situation is a bit out of control
Katrina: 你这是要摆烂
Katrina: Are you just giving up
Jake:一直是失一直是失控的状态哈哈
Jake: It's always been out of control, haha
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn
Lucia: 那要不摆烂吧
Lucia: Why not just give up
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 快勾人快快勾人
Shure: Quick, hook them, quick, quick
Shure: 勾人快快
Shure: Hook them, quick
Shure: 你不急吗勾
Shure: Aren't you anxious, hook
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
其他人：开摆了已经开摆了
Others: It's already a mess, it's a mess
Shure: 我好急
Shure: I'm so anxious
其他人：我采访一下你以前吃的非常够吗
Others: Let me ask you, did you eat enough before
其他人：牛逼哈哈哈
Others: Awesome hahaha
Jake:你回头
Jake: Turn around
Alice:逐渐同化
Alice: Gradually assimilating
Jake:你回头再测一下
Jake: Turn around and test it again
Shure: 今天晚上20岁也别测一下
Shure: Don't test it tonight when you're 20
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:你今天晚上当着我坐着别测一下
Jake: Sit in front of me tonight and don't test it
Shure: 啊我们今天
Shure: Ah, today we...
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Jake:屁人训练计划
Jake: Training plan for everyone
Shure: 把那个投投个屏开始给你测一下
Shure: Start the screen projection and let's test it
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 公开处刑
Shure: Public execution
Lucia: 这玩意能放哪啊
Lucia: Where can we put this thing?
Jake:我试试是不是这个没开啊
Jake: Let me check if this is not turned on
Jake:哦他这个没开
Jake: Oh, it's not turned on
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:确实没开
Jake: It's indeed not on
Jake:然后这个肯定是没插
Jake: And this one is definitely not plugged in
Lucia: 够够够够够
Lucia: Enough, enough, enough
Jake:这个是要不就插好了
Jake: This one is either plugged in
其他人:插好了
Others: It's plugged in
Jake:有电不是
Jake: There's power, right?
Jake:有电但是没开
Jake: There's power but it's not on
Shure: 你要找币
Shure: You need to find the coin
Jake:开了就就
Jake: Turn it on and then...
Jake:他显然没充电啊
Jake: It's obviously not charging
Jake:我靠这100%开玩笑的啊
Jake: Damn, this is 100% a joke
Jake:呵呵就是就是
Jake: Haha, just, just
Jake:他没开他有电但是没开
Jake: It's not on, it has power but it's not on
Shure: 你先把币找着行
Shure: You find the coin first
其他人：这还要开
Others: Does this still need to be turned on?
Tasha: 这打不开啊
Tasha: This can't be opened
其他人:那没电了呀
Others: Then it's out of power
Alice:嗯那个热水可以递给我一下吗
Alice: Hmm, can you pass me that hot water?
Jake:对要开机了
Jake: Yeah, it needs to be turned on
Jake:他得一直闪着他才有电
Jake: It has to keep flashing to have power
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is...
其他人:所以他机了是吧
Others: So it turned on, right?
Jake:他机了不是不是不是你插
Jake: He did it, no no no, you...
Alice:啊谢谢
Alice: Ah, thanks.
Tasha:200克就行
Tasha: 200 grams is enough.
Jake:了呀你
Jake: Yes, you...
Jake:他要有电
Jake: It needs power.
其他人：他有电吗
Others: Does it have power?
Jake:充电宝有电
Jake: The power bank has power.
其他人:OK
Others: OK.
Jake:但是你开着的时候他在充电
Jake: But it's charging when you turn it on.
Jake:他刚刚没有显示就没有电
Jake: It didn't show just now, so it had no power.
Jake:就是没有
Jake: It means it has no power.
Jake:没有在供电
Jake: It's not supplying power.
Shure: 你的计划没有用
Shure: Your plan isn't working.
Shure: 你把币给我找着
Shure: Find the coin for me.
Jake:就这个意思
Jake: That's what I mean.
Tasha:上哥现在就再来铺一层
Tasha: Let’s add another layer now.
Jake:现在
Jake: Now.
其他人:在这充电吧
Others: Let's charge it here.
Shure: 你快把币给我
Shure: Quickly, give me the coin.
Jake:啊这个在充电
Jake: Ah, this is charging.
Shure: 不然我就给你锁外边
Shure: Or I'll lock you outside.
其他人：嗯没了
Others: Hmm, that's it.
Lucia: 这是您刚才擦过的吗
Lucia: Is this the one you wiped earlier?
Lucia: 那放的那个
Lucia: The one you placed there.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 感觉已经控干了
Lucia: It feels dry already.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Tasha:上哥再铺一层
Tasha: Let's add another layer.
Lucia: 给他找个地方
Lucia: Find a place for it.
Lucia: 就这管他了
Lucia: Just put it here.
Alice:那边还有一包呢
Alice: There’s another bag over there.
Jake:这个就是在充电
Jake: This is charging.
Lucia: 这刀看起来是干净的
Lucia: This knife looks clean.
Jake:给他充一会吧
Jake: Let it charge for a while.
Lucia: 拜拜
Lucia: Bye bye.
Tasha: 买的居然刚刚好
Tasha: Surprisingly, what we bought is just enough.
其他人:对对
Others: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha:一般就是要铺两层
Tasha: Usually, we need to add two layers.
其他人:我觉得
Others: I think...
其他人:不然不如你直接把这个都搁里边
Others: Otherwise, you might as well put it all in there.
其他人::然后把这个稍微放里边
Others: And then put this inside a bit.
Tasha:不行
Tasha: No way.
Alice:那样会把底下的底给破坏了
Alice: That would ruin the bottom.
其他人:搞这么专业
Others: So professional.
其他人:这是专业脚
Others: This is professional work.
其他人:别学到这个是哪里
Others: Don't learn from this.
Lucia: 这还有两根哎
Lucia: There are two more left.
Tasha:这俩别浪费
Tasha: Don't waste these two.
其他人:这是干嘛的茶
Others: What is this tea for?
其他人：茶哈哈哈
Others: Tea, hahaha.
Alice:直接用手吧
Alice: Just use your hands.
Alice:你那个你那个有底
Alice: Yours has a base.
Alice:我放
Alice: I'll put it.
Lucia: 提拉米苏
Lucia: Tiramisu.
其他人:为什么为什么这样
Others: Why, why like this?
Tasha:哎你别搞这么快
Tasha: Hey, don't do it so fast.
其他人:为什么你这样子搞这么快啊
Others: Why are you doing it so fast?
Lucia: 为什么要提拉米苏
Lucia: Why tiramisu?
Shure: 怎么屡教不改呢刘帅
Shure: Why do you never learn, Choiszt?
Lucia: 就是做底
Lucia: It's for the base.
Lucia: 就是这个手指饼干
Lucia: It's this ladyfinger.
Shure: 还在跑
Shure: Still running.
Lucia: 这提拉米苏里面
Lucia: In the tiramisu.
其他人:等会再放等会再放
Others: Wait to put it in, wait to put it in.
Lucia: 他本本来
Lucia: It originally...
Lucia: 正宗提拉米苏就是用这个做蛋糕胚
Lucia: Authentic tiramisu uses this for the cake base.
其他人：啊啊啊他一会
Others: Ah, ah, ah, he'll...
其他人：他一会要跳起来抽你
Others: He'll jump up and hit you.
其他人:因为我感觉他真的已经非常重要
Others: Because I feel it's really important.
Jake:行行行开除开除开除
Jake: Okay, okay, you're fired, fired, fired.
Jake:好换一个换一个你
Jake: Alright, switch, switch, you.
Lucia: 这个也用不了吧
Lucia: This can't be used either, right?
其他人:你等他
Others: Wait for him.
Lucia: 就是钱钱一包里那个
Lucia: It's like the money in the bag.
其他人:你等他摆完你再放你等他摆完你再放
Others: Wait for him to finish, then put it, wait for him to finish, then put it.
其他人:我知道我知道
Others: I know, I know.
Jake:你知道个球
Jake: You know nothing.
Jake:你知道哈哈哈
Jake: You know, hahaha.
Shure: 好好的我错了但是我下次继续
Shure: Alright, alright, I was wrong, but I'll continue next time.
其他人:心里有数心里有数心里有数
Others: Keep it in mind, keep it in mind, keep it in mind.
Jake:有哈哈
Jake: Yes, haha.
其他人:哈哈哈来
Others: Hahaha, come on.
其他人:那怎么就多一层啊
Others: How come there's an extra layer?
Alice:那怎么办呢
Alice: What should we do then?
Tasha: 没事无妨
Tasha: It's fine, no problem.
其他人：哈哈哈你多吃一口多好
Others: Hahaha, just eat one more bite.
Jake:这是尖锐你知道吧哈哈哈
Jake: It's sharp, you know, haha.
其他人:哈就不能让你多吃一口
Others: Haha, can't let you eat one more bite.
其他人:不行这个ESP真的不
Others: No way, this ESP really doesn't...
其他人:这这这叫什么人格
Others: This, this, what's this personality called?
Lucia: 荣格荣格荣格巴维
Lucia: Jung, Jung, Jung, Bave.
Alice:荣格荣格巴维
Alice: Jung, Jung, Bave.
其他人:芭蕾说的非常的不准
Others: Ballet said it very inaccurately.
其他人:里面可能是人在骗你了
Others: Maybe someone inside is lying to you.
其他人:啥意思没事
Others: What do you mean? It's fine.
Lucia: 就是那个MBTI
Lucia: It's that MBTI.
Lucia: 他原本是荣格巴维理论然后脱胎的
Lucia: It originally came from Jung-Bave theory.
Lucia: 一个一个人格模型测试
Lucia: A personality model test.
其他人:这这一层是平这波
Others: This layer is flat, this wave...
其他人:这波无法
Others: This wave can't...
Alice:无妨开
Alice: It's fine, open it.
其他人:开但是有点浪费
Others: Open it, but it's a bit wasteful.
Alice:没事你剩下你可以吃边边角角
Alice: It's okay, you can eat the edges later.
Tasha:然后现场就吃掉
Tasha: Then eat it on the spot.
Tasha:现场就吃
Tasha: Eat it on the spot.
其他人:哎这其实也可以塞下是吧
Others: Oh, actually you can stuff it in, right?
其他人:就其他的啊
Others: Just the other parts.
Tasha:嗯现场就吃
Tasha: Yes, eat it on the spot.
Tasha:你准备几个小托盘
Tasha: You prepare a few small trays.
Tasha:咱们现场吃掉它好吃吗
Tasha: We'll eat it on the spot, is it tasty?
其他人:好吃吗
Others: Is it tasty?
其他人:所以这个蛋挞是我们自己开的书吗
Others: So did we make this egg tart ourselves?
其他人:还是买好的书
Others: Or did we buy it?
其他人:买好的那个
Others: We bought the crust.
其他人：买好的那个皮哦
Others: We bought the crust, oh.
其他人:哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:我们来b了
Jake: Let's go to B.
Jake:我们来b
Jake:哦哦可能在这里边
Jake: Oh, oh, maybe it's in here.
Lucia: 哎我今天早上还看见他了
Lucia: Hey, I saw him this morning.
Jake:b在哪啊
Jake: Where's the B?
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Tasha:吃吧吃吧
Tasha: Eat, eat.
Lucia: 在那吗不在
Lucia: Is it there or not?
Tasha:这个哎
Tasha: This one, hey.
Tasha:好吧最后一个还剩几个
Tasha: Okay, the last one, how many are left?
Tasha:我们吃掉
Tasha: We'll eat it.
Lucia: 哎哎哎
Lucia: Hey, hey, hey.
其他人:还有6 还有8个啊
Others: There are 6, there are 8!
其他人:6个哎这还有7个
Others: 6, hey, there are 7 here.
Lucia: 是吧哎呦不好意思
Lucia: Right? Oops, sorry.
Lucia: 感觉好像也不在这
Lucia: Feels like it's not here either.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh...
Lucia: 我今天肯定看见他了反正
Lucia: I definitely saw it today though.
其他人:什么东西
Others: What thing?
Jake:币
Jake: The coin.
Lucia: 我们的那个最后一天作为通货的
Lucia: Our last day using it as currency.
Jake:您您知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
其他人:没币
Others: No coin.
Jake:没币在哪
Jake: No coin, where is it?
Tasha:我记得在这
Tasha: I remember it's here.
Tasha:桌子上
Tasha: On the table.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:哪个桌子上
Jake: Which table?
Tasha:就在这个桌子上
Tasha: On this table.
Jake:这个桌子上
Jake: This table?
其他人:b吗
Others: Is it B?
Jake:好咱还有更多的桌子吗
Jake: Do we have more tables?
Lucia: b吗咱还有更多的桌子吗
Lucia: Is it B? Do we have more tables?
Jake:呵呵b
Jake: Haha, B.
Lucia: 这是不是可以扔了
Lucia: Can we throw this away?
Jake:你现在很难知道我长什么样子
Jake: It's hard to tell what I look like now.
Tasha:好无语的样子
Tasha: You look so speechless.
其他人:这是b吗
Others: Is this B?
Tasha:这是贴画呀啊
Tasha: This is a sticker, right?
Lucia: 呃不是这个
Lucia: Uh, not this one.
Alice:贴画呀呃不是这个
Alice: A sticker, uh, not this one.
Tasha:呃不是这个贴画吗
Tasha: Uh, isn't this the sticker?
Lucia: 啊不是不是
Lucia: Ah, no, no.
Lucia: 我没说你说的
Lucia: I wasn't talking about what you said.
Lucia: 我说不是我拿的这个东西
Lucia: I said it wasn't me who took this thing.
Jake:不是不是不是不是b
Jake: No, no, no, no, no.
其他人:不是b
Others: No, no.
Jake:b是圆的
Jake: B is round.
Alice:圆的
Alice: Round.
Jake:圆圆的圆的
Jake: Round, round, round.
Jake:贴纸贴纸贴纸贴纸贴纸
Jake: Sticker, sticker, sticker, sticker, sticker.
Jake:确实藏挺好啊
Jake: It's really well hidden, huh?
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们自己都找不见了
Lucia: Hahaha, we can't even find it ourselves.
Lucia: 对对对已经藏好了
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, it's already hidden well.
其他人:能藏在哪啊
Others: Where could it be hidden?
Lucia: 现在是帮的环节
Lucia: Now it's the helping stage.
Lucia: 就大家一起找
Lucia: Everyone just look together.
其他人:找到币了
Others: Found the coin.
Jake:藏挺好藏
Jake: It's well hidden.
Jake:藏哪了
Jake: Where is it hidden?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎上面的桌子上
Lucia: Hey, on the table above.
其他人：哦高级
Others: Oh, that's advanced.
其他人：我知道藏哪了
Others: I know where it's hidden.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure: 藏到你的
Shure: Hidden in your...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahahahaha.
其他人:是不是这个
Others: Is it this one?
其他人:就是这个
Others: It's this one.
其他人: 不是就是这个
Others: No, it's this one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈怎么回事
Lucia: Hahaha, what's going on?
Jake:什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
Lucia: 猛男脱衣舞
Lucia: Male stripper dance.
Jake:哦哦哦这也能当币吧
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, this can be considered as a coin, right?
Jake:啊可以可
Jake: Yeah, it can be.
Jake:以当币这个算
Jake: It can be counted as a coin, this counts.
Shure: 但是我们就有假币
Shure: But we only have fake coins.
Shure: 这是良币
Shure: This is a good coin.
Jake:这这这算一分的吧
Jake: This, this, this counts as one point, right?
Jake:这类似于一块的
Jake: This is like a one-piece.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahaha.
其他人：警惕劣币驱逐良币
Others: Beware of bad money driving out good.
Lucia: 劣币驱逐良币
Lucia: Bad money drives out good.
Shure: 这是良币
Shure: This is good money.
其他人：劣币驱逐良币
Other: Bad money drives out good
Katrina: 这是每个人当中有几个人
Katrina: So, among everyone, how many are there?
Alice:这只有16多了
Alice: There are only 16 or so.
Shure: 这有150个吗
Shure: Are there 150 of them?
Jake:16的
Jake: 16 of them.
Lucia: 有吧一包50个啊行
Lucia: Yeah, there should be 50 in each pack, right?
Alice:不储存 1616够 16 够
Alice: No need to store more, 16 is enough.
Jake:1616 够16
Jake: 16 is enough.
Katrina: 我们每人参观一个房间
Katrina: We can each visit a room.
Jake:够16 再干20分钟
Jake: 16 is enough, we can continue for another 20 minutes.
Shure: 不是要藏在厅里边吗
Shure: Aren't we supposed to hide in the hall?
Alice:如果他没存储了自己断了
Alice: If he doesn’t store it, he’ll cut himself off.
Shure: 房间不是
Shure: The room isn't...
Alice:他应该是会存着吧
Alice: He should store it, right?
Katrina: 是要带他们参观房间
Katrina: We need to show them the rooms.
Jake:对会存会存
Jake: Yeah, he will store it.
Alice:哦那就好
Alice: Oh, that's good.
Lucia: 藏壁区你别笑话我
Lucia: Hide it in the wall, don't laugh at me.
Shure: 你也见不得人
Shure: You can’t be seen either.
Katrina: 你别笑话我你喂
Katrina: Don't laugh at me, hey.
Katrina: 你要藏自己房间吗
Katrina: Are you going to hide in your own room?
Jake:来我藏自己房间吗
Jake: Should I hide in my own room?
Jake:不用藏房间
Jake: No need to hide in the room.
Lucia: 主要是藏房间的话藏外面就行了啊
Lucia: If we hide in the room, just hide outside.
Jake:不藏房间
Jake: No hiding in the room.
Lucia: 那就好
Lucia: That's good.
Jake:就在外边
Jake: Just outside.
Lucia: 要不然行李没地放
Lucia: Otherwise, there's no place for the luggage.
Alice:藏那上面呗
Alice: Hide it up there.
Jake:不能让他们爬
Jake: They can't climb.
Lucia: 不能让他
Lucia: They can't...
Lucia: 难度是不是有点太高了
Lucia: Isn't it a bit too hard?
Lucia: 哈哈不能让他们碰到
Lucia: Haha, they can't touch it.
Jake:不能让他们碰到相机
Jake: They can't touch the camera.
Katrina: 院子也可以是吧
Katrina: The yard works too, right?
Jake:燕子可以不能爬相机
Jake: The yard is fine, just don't climb on the camera.
Alice:能藏这里面
Alice: Can we hide it in here?
Shure: 你
Shure: You...
Jake:我去哈哈哈
Jake: I'll go, haha.
Alice:哎这怎么连个拉锁都没有
Alice: Hey, how come there's no zipper here?
其他人：你们到底藏哪了
Others: Where are you hiding?
Shure: 我们还没藏呢
Shure: We haven't hidden yet.
Jake:你就我们找到了找
Jake: You can try to find us.
Shure: 你找找你再找
Shure: Keep looking, keep looking.
Jake:藏这了藏这了就
Jake: Let's hide here, let's hide here.
Lucia: 150
Lucia: 150.
其他人：150坏了
Others: 150 is broken.
Jake:150 我们匀个50来藏还是多少来着
Jake: 150, we can split 50 to hide, or how much was it?
Lucia: 用来藏多少
Lucia: How much to hide?
Jake:藏个20吧
Jake: How about 20?
其他人：20很难藏
Others: 20 is hard to hide.
其他人：就这么大
Others: It's that big.
Jake:藏20吧能藏在每个人的房间吗
Jake: Hide 20, can we hide them in each person's room?
Jake:不能不能就20吧
Jake: If not, then just 20.
Alice:藏这吗
Alice: Hide here?
Alice:就这底下
Alice: Just under here?
Jake:藏他20底下能让嘉宾往下爬
Jake: Hide 20 under here, can the guests crawl down?
Katrina: 要让嘉宾往下爬
Katrina: Do the guests need to crawl down?
Alice:他不一定
Alice: Not necessarily.
Alice:他不一定会爬呀
Alice: They might not crawl.
Jake:藏他20个哈
Jake: Hide 20 of them.
其他人:是不是ECO friend
Others: Is it ECO friendly?
其他人:我以为是environmental friend
Others: I thought it was environmental friend.
Shure: 不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:呃是都可以都可以都可以
Jake: Uh, it can be both, both are okay.
Shure: 可能他要打把e后局吧
Shure: Maybe he wants to play another game after e.
Jake:能冲进去
Jake: Can we rush in?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:这每个都长不一样吗
Alice: Are they all different lengths?
Katrina: 嗯应该是
Katrina: Hmm, probably.
Alice:是多少组啊
Alice: How many groups?
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What?
Jake:拿我的哼
Jake: Take mine, hmm.
Tasha:你不相信我的数据线
Tasha: You don't trust my data cable?
Jake:不我就不相信你的充电宝
Jake: No, I just don't trust your power bank.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake:相信我的充电宝
Jake: Trust my power bank.
Katrina: 二楼厅也可以藏
Katrina: The second floor hall can hide too.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 感觉我藏完明天就忘了自己藏哪了
Lucia: I feel like I'll forget where I hid them by tomorrow.
Jake:你试试
Jake: You try it.
其他人：藏
Others: Hide it.
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 你放在哪里了
Lucia: Where did you put it?
Lucia: 哦哎很棒
Lucia: Oh, that's great.
Jake:大对大伙藏
Jake: Hide it from everyone.
Jake:然后给我们
Jake: Then give it to us.
Jake:就我们内部先知道一下
Jake: Let's keep it internal for now.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 好吧估计内部明天就忘了
Lucia: Alright, we'll probably forget it by tomorrow.
Jake:对对对不然自己都不记得了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, otherwise we'll forget it ourselves.
Lucia: 海盗船长忘记了宝藏牌在哪里
Lucia: The pirate captain forgot where the treasure map is.
Lucia: 全剧终
Lucia: The end.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 看我藏那了
Shure: Look where I hid it.
Shure: 是不是不易被发现
Shure: Isn't it hard to find?
Alice:哎等一下
Alice: Hey, wait a minute.
Jake:哪哪啊你藏哪了
Jake: Where, where did you hide it?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 牛吧
Shure: Awesome, right?
Jake:牛
Jake: Awesome.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Alice:你别动
Alice: Don't move.
Jake:那给我一个
Jake: Give me one.
Jake:我也要藏
Jake: I want to hide too.
Alice:我也要这能藏藏
Alice: I want to hide too.
Jake:藏人头上是吧
Jake: Hide it on someone's head, right?
Jake:我觉得可以藏
Jake: I think we can hide it.
Jake:藏头里藏里
Jake: Hide it in the hair.
Jake:发卡里哈哈哈
Jake: In the hair clip, hahaha.
Shure: 我这头发能
Shure: My hair can...
Shure: 能藏藏20个是吧
Shure: Can hide, like, 20 of them, right?
Lucia: 放书架上了
Lucia: Put it on the bookshelf.
Jake:嗯这咋藏的
Jake: Hmm, how did you hide it?
Alice:哎呀找一个瘦一点的
Alice: Oh, find a thinner one.
Shure: 你看我那就很不明显
Shure: Look, mine is really not obvious.
Lucia: 你看我那就
Lucia: Look at mine...
Alice:哎呀没有掉
Alice: Oh, it didn't fall.
其他人:很明显了
Others: It's very obvious.
其他人:我藏了一个
Others: I hid one.
其他人：那另一个包
Others: The other bag.
Jake:你藏哪去了
Jake: Where did you hide it?
Jake:哪啊
Jake: Where?
其他人:那
Others: There.
Tasha:你怎么
Tasha: How did you...
Tasha:被你发现了
Tasha: ...figure it out?
Jake:哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure: 不好找你就不
Shure: If it's hard to find, then don't...
Jake:哈哈没有没有不好意思不好意思
Jake: Haha, no, no, sorry, sorry.
Jake:我以为这是个桌子
Jake: I thought it was a table.
Jake:哈哈不好意思
Jake: Haha, sorry.
Katrina: 谁把我头摁了
Katrina: Who pushed my head?
Jake:哈哈在在哪在哪啊在哪
Jake: Haha, where, where, where?
Lucia: 这在哪在哪
Lucia: Where is it, where?
其他人:我告诉你都找不着
Others: I'll tell you, you won't find it.
其他人:那那就完蛋了
Others: Then it's over.
Jake:我靠这你确实确实
Jake: Damn, you really, really...
Jake:我真以为这个桌子
Jake: I really thought it was a table.
Tasha:这个位置要藏几个啊
Tasha: How many can we hide in this spot?
Jake:因为原来这有个桌子
Jake: Because there used to be a table here.
Tasha:这个人已经藏了一个了
Tasha: Someone already hid one here.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 那是已经藏了一个的吗
Lucia: So, one has already been hidden?
Lucia: 好吧哎
Lucia: Alright, well...
Lucia: 这不好像不是
Lucia: This doesn't seem to be it.
Lucia: 这是标签
Lucia: It's a tag.
其他人:哎呦我靠
Others: Oh my god.
其他人:真看不到你怎么拿出来
Others: You really can't see it, how did you take it out?
Alice:这是贴的
Alice: It's stuck on.
Shure: 我想问你
Shure: I wanted to ask you...
Shure: 这是贴的
Shure: ...if it's stuck on.
Jake:对对对这个破坏道具了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, this broke the prop.
其他人:不都全傻的吗
Others: Aren't we all fools?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha:这是一个隐藏爆款
Tasha: This is a hidden bestseller.
其他人:我靠确实
Others: Damn, indeed.
Jake:这又是哪啊
Jake: Where is this now?
Lucia: 那里面哈哈哈
Lucia: Inside there, hahaha.
Jake:哦这个里边
Jake: Oh, inside here
其他人:可以直接藏厕所垃圾桶塞
Others: You can just hide it in the bathroom trash can.
Shure: 塞我怕取不出来啊
Shure: I'm afraid I won't be able to get it out if I stuff it in.
Jake:哈哈你拉倒吧这怎么可能呢
Jake: Haha, come on, that's impossible.